[Music]
thank you
yes sir my check my check welcome to the
realm see how we sounding Out Here how
the levels is good talk to me around I
see some people in there already popping
out what's going on lieutenant ovb
what's going on deep estate Don't You
Buck up on me Sinister whatever thank
you brother what's going on Christopher
what's going on being messy already I
see you
he's Texas uh Xbox error what's going on
uh am I going in the building way heck
was the game with that next salute Xbox
error do me a favor
um I know the time zone is a little
different for uh a little special dick
because someone give him a call just to
make sure
as soon as I said that a little a little
nervous then he said okay cool he just
responded so this man is the trooper you
know what I mean he's for the other side
of the world and he's gonna be coming in
here getting it popping so he's good
let's see another Roll Call Shout Out
Lydia Master what up Stu Jersey what up
this pain PR what's going on but he goes
in the house we already know
Punchy what's up no doubt no doubt Astro
parrot King Lloyd Metroid switch coming
in hot I see you
Kelly and brown what's going on command
the rider missile right up right up
right no doubt he said this pain you
guys killed the last year this guy's
gonna work go out and listen man we got
big things planned we hopefully
hopefully that's the plan you know what
I mean but um yeah we got some fun we
got a fun show a lot to talk about oh
astral parrot young Cog is coming what's
up what's up you like those those picks
I throw backs I I showed you right I
told you man of my word man of my word I
had that but um yeah we got some fun
today we got a lot to talk about we're
gonna get
Lord of Xbox Australia in the building
you know what I mean we're gonna get
them in here addict talk to the people
right quick make sure they can hear you
what's going on guys
no doubt so we are gonna go get my means
special Nick and go get the rest of them
Awards we got a lot to talk about have
some fun and we will see y'all in a
minute
[Music]
thank you hear you hear you man welcome
to the show if you would not mind go hit
it up find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all the good
stuff that we need to do in um you know
we're about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns uses the
target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but a man time
social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold y'all
I ain't here to boil you ain't gotta say
it I'm embarrassed for you I always been
a nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell an Uber because it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn
look You Oughta messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard the boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with Django cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just to
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my CD but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know about to get
started I am well it's not important who
I am uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um I hell look You
Oughta messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and sampling making
it flammable this is that this is the
Yoga Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up
in the apartment they call a department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless and
people don't aim check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my TV
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
cool
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee Bender I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he flies you still
a mosquito you swear you ain't nothing
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if he really was that joke he ain't
never still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday a suitable
cause you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the Lord day radio
[Music]
all right let's do a little mic check
mic check right quick talk to the people
how you doing hello
yes yes yes all right everybody else
let's get a little Nick mic check real
quick just we'll see if it comes through
an amazing uh yep am I sounding okay oh
perfect glorious all right here you hear
you and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 288.
this is another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
date I'm extremely excited about our
special guests and we've got three four
three layoffs and the future of Halo
scale bound and gears rumors Marvel
Avengers shuts down and Ubisoft strike
to discuss so we gonna get right into it
why is King laughing I want to introduce
the Lord whose passion for the Xbox
platform and rise from the era of gaming
forums has easily cemented him with a
golden eye for industry news and of
course what's going on
introducing the co-founder of
xboxera.com and the co-host of the Xbox
era podcast
the Lord of Xbox Australia and Ice
lattes
Survivor of Randolph or vicious rubic
criticism
and the closest Pablo Schreiber Master
Chief
from Melbourne and finally making his
crossover debut into the realm of the
Lord
my man Lord special Nick of Xbox era how
are we doing sir
g'day gentlemen how are you all how we
doing how we doing it's that early in
the morning for you you'd have to get up
early for this yes
at 5 00 a.m it's very difficult to live
up to an intro like that
waking up the entire house so I will be
somewhat muted to begin with but I'll do
my best to pick it up as I keep going
totally understand thanks for having me
guys thanks for coming thanks for coming
man again appreciate you the extra
effort required with the time zones
involved but uh what have you been
playing sir what's going on with you man
what have I been playing yes
um what have I been playing uh I started
playing Cana oh on PlayStation 5 it was
on sale so I picked it up and started
playing that and I was saying yesterday
that it um it reminded me a lot of
um Star Fox Adventures oh yeah okay
in a good way because I was a big fan of
that game
um
and I'm enjoying it so far but aside
from that I've been flat out I haven't
been playing a lot of games I was in
Sydney yeah if any of you saw our show
last week I've been in Sydney for a week
um so I haven't been playing a hell of a
lot
um I was actually playing
do any of you guys I didn't know this
until literally last week taught us did
you guys know there's like a Bejeweled
rip-off inside the Xbox app no
okay exhaust talk to me about this
there is a Bejeweled rip-off
within the Xbox app called Microsoft
Jewel
Ry and I had no idea about this until
last week I started playing that while I
was in Sydney and it is surprisingly
addictive really okay you gotta go it's
it's pretty damn good it's cool so it's
called jeweled that's what it is it's
regular Microsoft Jewel and this yes I
see it I see it wow wow okay I see it
right now yep
interesting
so pretty much any travel I see you've
been moving around you you kind of
disrespected um what you call it um five
guys but you know I understand the price
I just said the price I would have
played Factory with that
very
surprisingly expensive 19 cheeseburger
was
that was something else especially when
you're used to paying a few bucks for a
macca's cheeseburger not the macca's
cheeseburger is better than a Five Guys
cheeseburger but respectfully yes that's
interesting I had to give you a little
message I totally understand no doubt
we're gonna have some fun we're gonna
get into it so you already know we got
the original Four Horsemen of gaming
those original ones in the realm here at
the round table my codes for the cold
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show how
are you doing sir
doing pretty good I've actually you know
I've played a lot of yesterday I played
Fire Emblem I see a little stream going
on what's going on with that yeah
actually I I was the first Fire Emblem I
really sucked my teeth into was uh three
houses it was the previous Fire Emblem
and I actually feel like this game is
better than three houses oh yeah I've
I've really enjoyed this game what's
funny is since I don't know the origins
of Fire Emblem like how this game is
it's like you have like a pretty much
like a someone that is in a ring that
you could combine with to make one
person okay like a soul and I'm like
who's like I see this smart dude in
Smash Brothers but I have no clue who he
came from and people in the chat's like
attic that's that's that's the main
character from the first game
they're like oh okay so I think it's
cool they they've brought back main
characters it seems like from older
games is these spirits and like pretty
much what happens is like this giant
entity called the fell Dragon uh started
like Conquering the world and they
brought these these Warriors from other
Realms to help fight them and and then
after you because the the first fight is
you fighting the fell Dragon I think uh
and that's what I took from it okay and
then like you go you go to sleep for
thousands of years or something like
that it's it's it's it's it's a good
game so far it's a really in-depth jrpg
little down shout out to Nintendo
showing show up a man some love right
there with these Stella reviews anything
else besides the Fire Emblem joint but
that's it
um
that's what I played a little bit of
vampire survivors I still I still have
no clue
you know maybe I just need to like
educate myself more on this game but
it's just like geez like like I'll be
doing the same Mission like 30 times and
not get it like and not getting anything
for it it's like oh we're gonna give you
some gold to unlock something like I
don't know it's just it's hard for me to
like explain it like so I think the the
one I the
the power up I like the most is garlic
okay I like that I like them I like the
Bibles though the Bible's just about to
drive me well I like garlic with the
Bibles yeah yo that is crazy the garlic
yeah I figured that's a nice colorful so
question question are you looking at the
map no no I'm not asking are you looking
at the map and looking for like the the
secret things that are on each day
I got something that said like combine
weapons or something like that well
there's certain weapons that Wednesday
like once you um once you elevate like
the once you uh you have to evolve them
like you evolve them and then certain
ones in the evolved States when used
together become something else as well
but if you look at the map you'll find
question marks and stuff like that
because what that's what I kind of did
in the beginning where I would just stay
in a certain area and let the monsters
come to me yeah if you start traversing
the map you will get question marks that
pop up like hey what's that so you'll be
unlocking all the characters you'll be
finding other
um like other special uh abilities and
stuff like that so you kind of have to
like move around the map even though it
is kind of like in a kind of in a
limited runner in that way like it looks
like that but it's not it's not like
that's terrified that's terrified yeah
I'm playing the game
it seems just like a long
the hallway
hey are you still in the forest or have
you gone to the other stages I've went
to the other stage yeah yeah because
like on the dairy board you have to get
the milk and the werewolves to chase you
um but on the milk you also have to get
the the rotted cheese you have to find
with a rotted cheeses and there's no
cues on the board so you have to go all
around the boards in order to eat stuff
I'm like keep in mind none of this is
explained in any way shape or form
yeah no no so you can't go to each away
you just gotta go you know
well I'm just saying it's like I noticed
a couple of things you know about this
generation
I need the handheld for certain things
no I'm sorry but knowing the concept of
what the game is about is is it
handhelding okay anyway that's been it
sir the dell and of course s tear gang
number one we have our most technical
gamer Lord the solo game of this but the
single players selfish experience and
also the Sasha Davis the Lord cloud of
clarity and patreon of the iron bank my
man Lord someone very Dapper at the New
York game awards sir oh thank you as
well sir
I believe the word uh the words are who
are those guys
I will say one thing I've never had
someone make a video about me that's
something I tweet that's like saying
that star feels like into it yeah
yeah that was beautiful
yeah it was a great week it was a great
great week obviously you guys to check
social media so that the Lords were at
the New York game awards um very very
very yes nicest man I had a good time
with my Bros it was good since the first
event I've ever seen solve go to it's
like we gotta go next year yeah
it's always bougie we know when when
it's a bougie type event that that
tuxedo life and you gotta get flood and
the liquor and it's to his liking it's a
different song and this is the thing
though right I was I told King I was
like I wanted to strangle you and Cog
for deciding that we needed to go in
suits because it was short notice we
didn't think about it early on and then
when I looked at the previous videos of
like previous years I was like it's
National you know whatever we don't need
all that but King was wrong as always
he's right
listen I've never ever seen that level
of access to such high level people in
the industry where them being so you
know affable and welcoming and for you
just to stand there and talk to them yes
and you go to E3 you have a multitude of
people trying to get to these people to
talk to them everything is everybody's
bringing around security around them
this is a different vibe completely
New York Chic yes yes and when when I
when I explained New York Chic to people
they don't get it like it's the same way
as explaining New York Pizza you know um
it's it's flavorful it's functional
that's right and it gets straight to the
point right you go buy New York Pizza it
don't bend it don't fold it don't break
Fold It Up have a point and you just eat
your pizza there you go and you're able
to do something else with your other
hand like you could be on the phone you
can multitask facts uh New York Pizza is
the essence of New York right this was
the essence of New York I saw the Muse
the most eclectic people in one space
right and it range from uh your wallet
was crazy like the wallet game in it was
crazy it was crazy
yo no no what I'm saying is this
it rained it went from range zero to
range a thousand right yeah right and
and it wasn't a barrier yes you know
normally uh yo yo pop your pockets
dictate your conversations to
individuals not there and I gotta give a
shout out to Harold uh yeah yeah
Goldberg
um
Harold is the most interesting man I've
ever met in my life yeah yeah and he's
the man I aspire to be right because
this guy
and I don't know how the hell he did it
yeah
he is still that same Toys R Us kid yeah
you know it it's genuine and this is in
his eyes because when we got in there I
see this guy he's standing off to the
side but he is not being intrusive he's
just being observant of everyone walking
and he sees everyone and the joy in his
eyes is amazing yeah for sure he gets
something he tells his story and I'm
looking at him and then I find out that
his organization works with kids in the
Bronx
my heart man my heart like we we were we
were actually embarrassed that we didn't
know about yes what his organization was
doing before because it was like you
know we could have we could have been
helping in this in some way shape or
form for years already we just had no
idea
um and then you see like one one of one
of the co-hosts of the show along with
Reggie and Harold himself was was this
was a student who recently re just
recently was able to get out of a
shelter with her family and and get a
home and she was up there co-hosting go
to the shoulder with Reggie yeah and
speaking of you know we're already you
know being sort of raised in the Bronx
and and coming from that you know a cog
and I got an opportunity to speak to him
briefly at the end of the night and what
he told us he told us how everything
about the organization moved us and how
the fact that he was so involved with
the organization was a big deal he says
well you know what your job is now right
yeah the job is to take all of that and
move forward and continue to grow it
yeah and and that that meant a lot to us
and and it's just the fact that you had
Reggie Fusion made Phil Spencer Todd
Howard Jeff Keeley other other
luminaries from from the industry in
this small space when I tell you there
were moments in the after party where
no one was talking to Reggie yeah
they were just unassuming in a corner
having a drink and and it was like Nev
at E3 that's never gonna happen you
never have all those people in that room
with that level of energy and it is it
was just it was a Vibe it was good it
was you have you have musicians you had
game designers you had Architects you
had writers I mean uh you had the people
from Kotaku there yeah yes you know uh
it was just polygon yeah over there
axios yeah yeah PC Gamers of the
buildings yes incredible anything else
it was a yeah it was beautiful man it
was beautiful uh like I said we gotta go
this is already a year
this is the thing so addict we gotta get
that finish yeah
sure because I saw all the pictures you
guys were posting
Todd Howard
in almost every photo I saw of him and
I'm sure this is just a Todd Howard
thing because I used to get told I have
resting in the face and
every photo I saw of Todd Howard he
looked like he just CBF like he was just
the look he had on his face was like
take this photo and let me get out oh no
no no no no I mean that that's probably
just that's probably just the face he
sort of trained himself down yeah for
everything that's what I thought moments
before that he's super affable smiling
laughing with you like I said when he
saw us he was like oh you guys are
looking spiffy and like you know and
I'll let King and and uh and uh and so
it's just to get into it but again they
had a little back and forth yeah it is
very very
sarcastically sarcastic yeah yeah super
out super affable everybody was super
feeling that was the case yeah it
started it right it's when he get takes
his picture he gets into that yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're not catching nothing
yeah so um yeah beyond that again
vampire survivors this week um I don't
actually I had a bunch of like esteem uh
cards that I got for Christmas so I
downloaded the uh
the GTA Trilogy Definitive Edition on on
Steam to see how that works there and uh
very nice
um they fixed a lot of stuff from when
it launched
um still can't get it to run a 60 on a
dance team deck having trouble with the
steam deck bro I don't care I don't care
if they rebuilt these games in unreal
fire why is it not run against 60 on a
steam deck I don't know maybe it's the
steam deck yeah shut up
beyond that the Tinker watch watch The
Last of Us um
I'm so surprised that something that
follows the game sort of so beat for
beat is able to fill in the blanks in
ways that make sense you know tell me
you you you didn't watch RNR without
telling me you didn't watch our night
at this point I just I just assume
neither of them watch
so wide fraud alerts because we can't we
can't say our opinion we our opinion
doesn't matter
the reason why I'ma say this because
either either you doing the game and you
name dropping because uh that interview
was it was first and then the show came
after the interview right our Show
Arnold the Lord came afterwards so you
could have reference what was fresher
you know King and attic was right when
the assessment of the breakdown I'm just
saying okay so from the guy who doesn't
watch other podcasts because he doesn't
want his opinion tainted do you want me
to watch a podcast to take my pictures
[Laughter]
right so the opinion that comes from my
brain
I just didn't like your Source
credibility
no resource was mean from now without
every movie thought is R&R the Lord
make sure you preface it with r and all
first
exactly check out check us out please
listen to My Demo please check y'all out
after why would I I don't want to tape
myself with it and then all of a sudden
I'ma come over here and be like talking
like no
oh so but it's okay to talk like Gene
Park oh you could you could throw that
up that was me that was me
it
takes all the major beats this is how
you you show reverence to the source
material
and you fill in the blanks and you give
context for different characters and
things like that
the performances I thought were amazing
yeah so it's an extra question yes sir
do you think Neil druckman was sitting
there with a shotgun just in case
anybody went on script don't you go off
script I mean that's the thing though
like [__] up on me you could you could
tell you could tell there was like an
iron grip there like this is you're not
deviating from this I'm gonna paint in
the I'm gonna paint in the Extra Spaces
the way we see fit and that's the crazy
thing about this really does feel like
it is straight up naughty dog kind of in
control of the ship with HBO clout
behind them right and that's a special
mix man that's that's a very special mix
did you like I know and I want the room
to to please look left to the Halo TV
show and all look at left to the Halo TV
show
at the end of the day you know it if you
didn't or did like the Halo TV show you
can can look at that one episode of Last
of Us and watch the whole first season
of that Halo TV show and and clearly she
just turned into the Sony Microsoft name
he's talking about quality versus no I
just gave Credence to a whole live of
the monsters you can't debate me okay so
I worked very hard on the Halo TV
yes I won't be hearing any slams that
are on my way thank you we appreciate
your service thank you that's funny you
think you could silence me but anyway as
I was saying I
just like you you can look at one and
just like look like this this show
clearly didn't respect the fans that
that watch it want to do their own thing
and I would say that this other show
that you know and a lot of people were
like well this is going one for one no
one or the people who played the game
doesn't really have anything to look
forward to that's fine because we we
can't have it both ways we can't sit
there and say that we want them to stay
close to the material that someone makes
literally one-to-one with the material
well there ain't there ain't much to
change we we're not gonna have any any
difference of the story that's the point
yeah I mean because you can always fill
in the blanks there's always blanks to
fill in in the game right because the
game has to be structured in a certain
way to give you agency you're not going
to see every single thing and when you
think about it just the camera
perspective alone changes how things are
perceived if you do it right so yeah you
could have really done something that
was very very close to the games in
terms of Halo and still fill in the
blanks for somebody who's been a part of
that series and follow that Series in a
way that was meaningful so I think this
is a Learning lesson for a lot of games
to teach
translation it's not just Halo it's ever
it's the majority of of gaming
annotations like what just happened with
Resident Evil oh yeah it's like you like
you guys can make easily viewership and
money you guys just gotta care and
actually want the resource to be closed
before
um comparison because those movies make
boatloads of cash and Halo defense no
I'm talking about the TV show yeah the
people who don't yeah the people who
aren't Die Hard Halo fans apparently
yeah yeah man my wife enjoyed it she
enjoyed enjoyed the story that they made
I enjoy it right I'm not going to sit
here and cap and say I don't I'm a
Sci-Fi dude it was just Halo In a
Different Light it's in a different
light yeah I just took it as um like
Halo else worlds type of thing you know
in the Multiverse if Master Chief want
to take his face in his cheeks out oh it
would be you know
appreciate it I really do I feel like
that's a compound just say oh it's it's
a Multiverse of Massachusetts
the question was what did I do last week
listen RNR with the Lord's Tuesdays
thank you very much sir thank you very
much
sorry shout out to Christopher Hart time
the not walk in the plank on the 20th of
January shout out to you my brother
congratulations
man I'm gonna tell you man you're Chris
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the access gamer oh the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues demands nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
I'm doing fantastic I want everybody to
go follow my man Brian all right go
follow him right there okay okay he is
um the guy who got the
Wolverine statue oh
the
um PS4 Pro I didn't understand why I was
doing this uh what's going on what's
going on well
it was
um my son's birthday so
hello 12 years old okay wow so it was
you know his 12 year old birthday and
you know
he was bothering me for a couple of
weeks about the PlayStation 5. yeah
trying to get him that freshman PS5 yeah
so
um no
no Daddy gotta get the noodle
I gotta give you my history right yeah
yeah exactly my history none of my
parents ever brought any of my consoles
yeah ever all right so but I had every
console known to man oh
right so I had Atari 2600 and up
ColecoVision and television everything
vetrex everything every console that
ever released On My Own by myself right
all right so when I tell him this he's
sitting there with a horrified look
he's like do I have to do that down he's
like you know Daddy's got me everything
and he looked at me like you poor best
you had to endure this they are they are
monsters father
but you know he's he's he has received
everything but you know PlayStation 5 is
probably in the card for him later
and it's just more I mean I don't really
have to get it because all the
PlayStation 5 games and Playstation 4
back
I'm just saying just like I mean that's
me throwing a little bit shape yes all
right so a little bit of Shame he gets
his gift right
you know we take them out bring them
home so he sets up his uh his uh Xboxes
I get him every other weekend sir so he
sets up his Xbox and I and I said you
set up everything he said yeah every
everything is hooked up huh and he's
looking
I was like I don't think you set up
everything
like but he's well all the wires look
intact and then I was like um did you
set up this and you know we had the the
PlayStation Pro Battlefield Edition
[Music]
so he loses it my wife sees that uh his
Xbox has 925 games he's like oh my God
925k he said yeah yeah Daddy Daddy gets
busy
then I said wait till you unlock you
know the PlayStation he goes there he
sees the collection I think PlayStation
collection has like at least 900 some
odd games there too as well and he has
been
introduced to the PlayStation Classics
yes because he got you know I paid for
the monthly thing so you know we pay for
the year he has everything when you talk
about giving the a child a universe and
just stepping back and without bothering
you without being intrusive without
saying anything just go just go check
this stuff out and he asked me Daddy
does anything that you recommend I said
yeah Jack and Dexter Ratchet and Clank I
said just you just go into when Sony was
great you know let's let's make Sony
great again go back to win God of War I
told him I say hey hey go check out God
of War when it was good oh right
five hours later his eyes Buck his eyes
is Buck like
and uh he's like I'm like what do you
need he said juice
I give him juice and chips and put a
couple of cupcakes on it I said all
right man go back at it keep it up all
weekend I don't think he took a a a
sleep yet he's gonna pass out when I
take him home but I hear him talking to
his friends for him asleep and he's
talking to his friends on Xbox and I
hear him say yo man this PlayStation
thing is for real he said I'm not trying
to Fanboy or nothing I'm hearing him he
said but they got some stuff in here he
said you need to get a PlayStation now
he said well what's your name he said
well I'm running off my father's but I'm
about to make mine he said no it might
be Kratos Kratos
but he has been indoctrinated into the
world and I want him to
keep like because I'm thinking of Harold
I'm always Harold's always going to be
the that guy in the back of my mind
I want him to keep that kid that same
face that I saw when I gave him you know
the the PlayStation I want him to keep
that joy in his heart because there's
nothing like that feeling of a new game
exploring a new world giving him a new
Galaxy something without a bias don't
don't hey don't force your bias on your
children
and let them find out what what's best
for them and you know if he turns into
his play a PlayStation dude from here on
there you're gonna handle the Betrayal
but I love him man I love him that's
we've been playing I was playing
fortnite this weekend vampire Survivor
and I downloaded the new persona games
but it was it's been a glorious weekend
so far okay um I noticed it was like
this little sword thing when you was
talking on your name and like a goal and
it was sword on he it was under my name
yeah
what's that about what's going on with
this oh okay so
um we have uh the road to packs yes
every year you know Pax is open or now
that it's getting right back to open we
went last year we go every year to packs
and you know financially it's uh it's
it's a tall task yes
yes it is so uh what we decided this
year is we'll put goals in place and it
goes in place for us to um as y'all can
see right now
we're going to achieve these goals and
uh the first one is a round table
podcast the next one is the Retro game
with the Lord and the other one is
Lord's player a co-op game with the
community and the last one is a live
podcast at Pax now y'all saw the podcast
we did uh with uh when we crossed worlds
with wicked good games
right so we're going to do a live uh
podcast because that you know that takes
money as well you know renting the room
and going through all this other stuff
so we have a goal set in mind and
everything that y'all contribute to the
show goes straight to this road to packs
packs East 2023 yes where you know loads
of gaming.net is going to have boots on
the ground information oh yeah and I can
give you the best assessment of that you
guys saw we when we went to the game
awards right there was people talking
about the game awards and we were at the
game awards there was people insinuating
about the game awards and we were
telling you from the floor and from the
horse's mouth what was going on so we're
trying to bring you that level of
coverage here like we do all the time
boots on the ground yeah actual
conversations with developers actual
gameplay in hand and actual uh
assessments of what's going on in the
industry while it's happening so please
help us attain our goal of PAX East 2023
and I I'm pretty sure with this great
community that we do have we will hit
the 100 percent with no problem at all
absolutely it's just you guys continuing
to do what you do already just now we
just kind of formulating it with a
window of like this is exactly where all
of your support goes to you all we're
pretty much doing now is we've always
said with that all the money goes back
into the show that we're just showing
you where it's going yeah let's pretty
much it doesn't change it's just we just
visually
yeah exactly the merch the 20 the acts
2023 merch taxi shirts will be available
uh hopefully by next week I'm having
those patches uh made up and we're gonna
have that in the store so uh you can
actually support that way as well so you
know run and get a packed shirt but all
the stuff that you do contribute to all
the stuff that you do buy all the super
chats that you use we'll go straight to
uh getting us to packs East 2023. shout
out to Lord Metro he said uh we did a
good job with the coverage especially
the Indies last year that was dope and
then shot the Tony Bryant said he'll be
there all four days so it's all
fantastic it depends on how well you
know here's the thing like
we're gonna have to rent a room or
something yeah because we'll be in
hotels for uh for packs yeah and we're
good no more creepy house
hi guys hey hi guys
yeah so there there's not gonna be like
a a room so we'll have to rent a room
I've had people multiple people ask
about hosting like a meet and greet or
is that how they pronounce it yeah uh
we'll have to see you we can see if we
can facilitate that
um but if we if we still have time
inside that room yeah that room will
probably be where the meet and greet at
and we'll we'll you know tweet it out
and you know people come in we hey
what's up like anything you see us on
the show floor just pull up yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah what's up keep in mind we
we will
be doing one of these for e32 and the
the live show I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say anything uh but uh we there's
a problem with a person in the community
that's going to be staying with this
yeah you know he might pull up to that
to that live show no doubt no doubt let
me real quick we got to break protocol
solve you want to get on God's Hitman
because he did something really cool
we got hit hold on a second I can get it
for you and then you catch up but shout
out to God's Hitman man thank you for
the amazing podcast let's get a live
podcast at pack so it's funny I just
copy pasted that one I'm like what are
you talking about it and keep in mind
too that you know he said make sure
y'all get some lapel bikes all right
brother we working both things I have
put from the last two podcasts that we
made in super chats I started the goal
with those in mind so like that's why
it's uh you know we ain't at zero
because I I wanted to make sure that you
guys get represented for the entire the
entire month because this is pretty much
a 2023 thing so I put that all of that
into uh I started with that money in
mind
let's go temper 21 drinks last night at
the show all right we'll see about that
brother but anyway
yeah anyway so thank you attic for the
uh screen share let's get back to
business and King if you're good I'll
get into my situation what are you good
oh um well um that's about it uh oh we
we were going to say about the banter
about uh Todd Howard yes and uh and Cog
and Sovereign myself so you know we go
over there and I mean Todd is um really
cool super inviting yes I'm not even
gonna lie like
rubbing elbows with giants feels
different when you know you're in that
environment it's just really it was a
very different environment okay I have
to caveat that and let you know it's not
the same we've been in E3 we've been in
meet and greets we've been at certain
places but this was the most laid back
relaxed environment that I've seen with
these individuals pref with that saying
we get over there and Todd is laughing
and stuff and I'm like hey what's going
on time or whatever he's like oh you
want to get the film like nah we want to
get to you yeah oh that's what's up so
he's like oh who you guys y'all look
nice all right because so this is our
first time seeing Todd I guess outside
still in them all the time but you know
Todd so
um
I told Todd uh no sob and Cog said uh
hey take your time on that
yeah yeah yeah I said I said hey hey
Todd don't listen to them oh oh no no no
we listen to everybody
that don't mean I listen yeah we we hear
everything here everybody it doesn't
mean I listen it seems like King was
trying to lead the Witnesses
in King's defense I was leading the
witness because we see him Nick right so
over there and I come up like the top
don't listen to what anybody's saying
you take your time with stuff and you
take your time so they can't come over
here but he interrupts all his brush in
between us and it's like look
you start talking about commitments and
things got to be on time and I'm like oh
my God
I'm like yo your heart don't pump
Kool-Aid
and then King's over here telling them
you know but you know they you know
there are things that were said that
happened here too like that yeah
so if you look at my picture right you
gotta look at my picture you gotta look
at the picture that he has with salt the
picture that he has was soft is a lot
more inviting yes yes the picture that
he has with me is like
this game gotta come out
the picture he has to solve is more
realistic this man knows what's up the
picture he has to do is like this man is
demanding The Impossible like this man
walked up to me with the spreadsheet and
said remember what you said
I think I think we're gonna have to keep
up with what we said
yo somebody said Kingston Don't You Buck
up on me
[Music]
Up Down on YouTube just talking about
Halo midnight launches all the stuff
that's going on shout out to the last
word you bought this tiger Travis we got
destiny the meme account on she's
absolutely hilarious talking about
everything that's going on before life
for a lot of change they literally
revamping this game it's insane that the
quality of life things they're about to
do and then as far as me as far as games
I've been on playing obviously Destiny
season this serif Final Fantasy Crisis
call really pick it up on the attic I'm
starting to get into the flow it's a lot
of material fusions did you did you see
that epic scene where they fought on the
midgard
stuff happening and then obviously
learning about the Buster sword and you
know Zach's still kind kind of annoying
to me be very happy go lucky but they're
called Zach the puppy whatever but you
know I I see where it's going and I see
that they're going to most likely
transform his character a little bit but
I I can't I care for the DMZ system is
starting to get to me I'm starting to
like it at the beginning he has that I'm
finally achieving my goals sensation and
then the further the game goes that he
realizes his goals is it what he thought
they were yeah he's that happy to be
here guy Soldier and I'm gonna that
changes you're starting to learn you
know and all that stuff so I'm having
fun with that uh can you be surprised
that actually shout out to DJ oral shout
out to say this did they finally I got
bullied in the uh Call of Duty Warzone
then
it's not that bad I go for it like I
played ones when I play the DMZ war zone
is good what zone is good clearly I am
trash I have not played these type of
games
different from other things
they was throwing me in the goulash it's
like I didn't even yo one joint I was
still parachuting in right murdered in
the end goulash
I didn't even get I didn't boots did not
touch the ground and I'm already dead so
salute
these kids will kill us they're Savages
shout out to the proximity chat they
wild with the mouth they they out of
pocket I'm just like man now DMZ is more
my type because it's kind of like PVE
PVP you know what I'm saying you play
co-op with your boys you're going from
point to point you're getting your
weapons you're getting attachments and
all that so listen the game is it's cool
I gotta get the campaign probably done
and stuff like that but I did have fun
on that and uh yeah that's pretty much
all I had on that as far as real quickly
again you see a PIN to the top of the
screen for all our um Volari lovers get
[__] give Laura get your game support
get your pillow again we're available
now in the UK in the EU 15 off use code
law 15 is tagged at the top support our
good friends and Valaria that'll be dope
and then I'm sorry
and I want to like really shout out this
community yeah they support it like we I
was very skeptical on the pillows
because I was concerned that you know we
could sell games easy because we talk
about games but when it comes to like
luxurious pillows
but you guys you guys showed up like in
big ways yes
and just to reiterate what we said
before everything that we do here goes
back in goes back in not a single person
takes a dime home like getting a check
and you know everything goes back into
the show I wish we had a hundred
thousand subscribers yeah that'd be
amazing man that's the goal right that's
the goal to always work towards but at
the end of the day like these
subscribers when you think about what's
going on in the gaming uh like the
editorial space the the uh the media
side like we're still we're we're
grinding over here because a lot of
these bigger places are losing a lot of
people yeah and just the Dynamics of
what it is to be gaming media is
changing all the time so for us you know
like I said all the support that you
guys give us goes a long way to be able
to be on the show floor and show you all
the stuff that we're doing so they
really have to look too much past just
what Gene said last sweet like yeah the
the Landscaping in the industry in terms
of coverage is changing you know it used
to be 80 85 90 you know uh higher in
media like IGN Gamespot now the
influencers podcasters Dave took a lot
of that percentage yeah absolutely and
uh for the game awards that I did I did
want to shout out you know a lot of
people that pulled up shout out to Mr
Joanna dark I see you up in there yeah
shout out to um from Microsoft he was
there
um so many people keighley we talked
about the majors you know what I'm
saying the funny real quick story I'll
just tell is that
um when I'm finally getting the chance
to talk to Phil because obviously Phil
received the legend award Pro you know
after that later on in the show so we
Kicking It Whatever what's going on so
we taking it and then it was just like
so what you've been playing is like not
too much but um vampire survivors while
I'm remote
so I'm talking about all right that's
cool so this solve his vampire survivors
comes over into our conversation he goes
yeah s tier vampire survivors right Carl
and I'm like
good game no this is it's a good game
this is the funny part okay okay so then
I go yeah eight here it's cool it's
great so then Phil is like but what do
you mean Carl can I go oh man so he was
like why didn't you have it as an S tier
like I played all the time it's like my
game of the year and I'm like oh man
you know what I would have said call
people like well you know we got an
episode of IOP where you can find that
information
so check us out I'm like bro I said look
Phil you know I feel it's good it's
great he's not a little bit I got crazy
hours in it it's my game of the year
like cop why don't you have that
I'm literally getting jumped
Phil Spencer and soft Reggie's in the
background laughing and I'm like oh I'm
just about to take this L right now
because I'm not trying to argue with
these people right now so yeah salute
salute to them I just rolled my eyes and
had to take my eyes off laughed but uh
you know what I
but other than that yeah shout out to
everybody who pulled up shout out to
Harold Grover like King said everything
he did for the kids the the scholarships
they gave away the teachings on screen
and a YouTube video games as part of
their curriculum shout out to the game
awards love yes bxo shout out to New
York Game Awards nominees very varied a
lot of things that didn't get shout outs
and other award shows you see pentamic
get some nominations you see Colton of
the lab get some nominations you know
what I'm saying vampire survivors and
Shout out the other ring they clean the
house Alden ring you and clean he told
me there was some really good
um really good rewards in general too
yeah yeah childish hypnosis it got to
the point it was alive you know I need a
better competitor she's ridiculous
should have got a wall I've been Molly
whopping them the messiest part of the
show and I'll be ending because we
probably poor Nick waiting oh the and
the messiest part of the show is they
had a section it's called best DLC
and everyone
exactly okay
and I'm like bro you can't do us like
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
the woman in front of us when the show
was over she was like you guys are so
entertaining with your banter back and
forth we're like this is the ILO pocket
this is our code I said I'm sorry should
I just follow the subscribe
Ragnarok let's go best DLC are we like
oh no bro yo that was so it was wild
funny I care for it that was the
messiest King has been but it was wild
funny and then I was messy cause shout
out to Destiny witchcraft
but you pulled it off they did the thing
so I was the loudest person with A1 I
was like let's go but yeah that was a
funny little behind the scenes for y'all
600 almost 700 people here we only got
100 something like stop playing yeah
yeah kick with trolling in the live
event yes he won yeah yeah shout out to
Tony Polanco too
yeah yeah yeah shout out to Tony Polanco
no doubt what was what was the name of
the game that the the the the the the
beat em up I forget I'm trying to
remember yeah
with the best intro going and the
developer had a attacker king shirt
oh man I'm forgetting about it all right
beautiful speech you had to be there it
was it was absolutely amazing love it or
you can go to my timeline
all right cool we have going on around
now super chats please uh soft let's get
switches and then we got it
okay hold on a second we'll go back we
got Gerald Mac member for two years five
dollars at the chat bang bang nine the
game all have the IOP salute the Lords
no doubt Gerald you dropped the uh Super
Chat late last week after we were off
air I couldn't get back to it I can't
find it right now but I know you did it
so thank you brother I appreciate it
yeah if you remember what you said or or
article bring it back up I'll read it
um then we got God's Hitman two dollar
Super Chat let's go 49ers let's go down
again let's go we got a big business how
about let's go Giants
oh oh God
lord remember for two boys two dollar
Super Chat my heart goes out to all
those who lost their jobs yes it has
been a very very rough weekend in gaming
oh yeah oh yeah then we have the black
Harry Potter
y'all was sharp at that event also Game
of the Year Hogwarts Legacy will be here
in a few weeks let's get ready Wizards
and witches that's right Lord Metro said
two dollar Super Chat last week Gene
like super metroid he knows Perfection
ah okay that was okay with Gene it was
oh it was uh I thought it was Joe Mack
um we got Hollywood rolls member for six
months five dollars which happy Sunday
to my favorite pod proud to see you guys
on Twitter at the awards doing your
thing prayers to all those out of work
and in and out of the industry
absolutely
we got free R Kelly five dollar Super
Chat really want to see how King tries
to spin Halo die okay we will see right
we're gonna get to that topic then we
got free R Kelly again five dollars we
chat let's keep it a thousand Microsoft
killed Halo and gears let these
franchises die so they can be reborn
they need to evolve nobody want to play
Grandpa game oh you want them all to
just become stepdaddies like they didn't
even get the cradles right
then we got Ava cab 72 remember for one
year five dollars per chat here's a gift
for you from the birthday boy great
present for me to listen to The Fresh
show keep it up guys slap the like
button thank you appreciate it Happy
Birthday to you appreciate it okay
salute I've got hargit to me remember
for one year five dollars for the chat
salute to the Lords on this somber
Sunday after the massacre of Halo
welcome to the realm Nick let's hope
this coming week will be full of good
news
let's put the crust in the chat for Lord
gold Tony Bryant remember for two years
upgrading to Lord gold appreciate
yourself
then we got free R Kelly again two
dollars Super Chat check out cradles
before they emasculated him Jesus
cradles can't have no feelings what's
wrong what's going on
shout out to the game when the games was
great let's go this is God's just man
the one that Cog went earlier the 20
which I thank you for amazing podcast
let's get a lot of podcasts that packs
yes let's do that thank you we got
Dragonheart Yobe all right remember for
one year five dollar Super Chat higher
extra security for Sovereign if let me
play with your joystick shoulders gotta
get some out of here through the secure
IOP tunnel facts facts yeah we can't let
that type of access
I just know wait my wife was like where
are you going again
excuse me
[Laughter]
the last of us really brought the
characters to life on screen meanwhile
Halo got Master Chief from fortnite on
the big screen
kind of funny
yeah there we go for the legend member
for two years five dollars Super Chat
Real Talk King King neon wife was a real
talk King me and King Real Talk King me
and the wife was at Walmart as she got
and she got mad at customer service and
said on God don't [__] up on me I was in
tears
[Laughter]
this is too much
all right let me scroll back a little
bit I think we got y'all baby yeah baby
two dollars my guys just getting so
sharp at the awards show blessed thank
you thank you
and we got Dan the Man Cunningham five
dollar Super Chat greetings Laura's love
what you guys do keep shining your light
Brothers good luck with your 49ers
tonight go Cowboys
no that's the time in the football club
yeah I'm Spartan goes 17 too fast to
protect damn The Last of Us show just
killed Halo sure
two separate things
smart goes 17 Tupac stupid chat Master
cheeks gotta pack it in boys special
Nick is here today we're not doing that
hey cut that out
there we got Corey Mosley five dollar
Super Chat great show guys keep up the
great work hit that like button no doubt
are we good yes
it has been very patient Nick has been
super patient yeah two hours I know
brother it probably works out for the
best with how quiet I need to be it
worked out you got another one yes we
have another one of them I get to this
Super Chat there needs to be some sort
of merch with Robin let me play with
your kids and we don't need merch for
this maybe something like single player
gamer only I play with myself wow
playing in front of a television oh man
that says Lord sovereign
[Laughter]
let go
you're stupid moving on now that we've
gotten care of the business and all that
other good stuff oh we gotta focus on
Nick his video game system history his
journey into podcasting Xbox error and
of course what led him to one of the
most Rising independent publication
websites that xboxera.com so Lord Nick
will start from the very beginning what
were some of the first video game
systems you had what got you in the game
here
um the arcades really uh that's that's
where I started as a kid I I was less
the consoles came a little bit later for
me
um yeah growing up I was almost always
in the arcades my my my only exposure to
consoles was sort of that friends houses
cousins houses so you know had one who
had an Atari another one who had like
Nintendo whatever the case was
um yeah I didn't get into the console
gaming until I was like eight okay which
I was a little bit older we're talking
1988 back then
um
give me some arcade games What drew you
into the to the lights if you can
remember
Street Fighter yes yeah but you're just
pushing me back yeah
remember one one in particular that'd be
cool we're talking like Wonder Boy oh
okay
let's go yes oh well yeah I was I was
very much a Sega Fanboy growing up
because of the arcade scene Sega back
then talking Australia was a lot bigger
than Nintendo I know it was the opposite
in the rest of the world
um like the Master System here outsold
than this wow really one of the very few
countries for that to happen in so I I
got a Master System as a kid and wow
you know I I I remember the key to
freaking out that games were on credit
cards remember the cards the Master
System had and you slot them in
you know the Master System had a free
built-in snail maze yeah
yeah I just remember thinking that was
just like the greatest thing ever as a
kid in fact you know got myself Wonder
Boy because that's what I played at the
arcades hang on oh my heart
yeah all that sort of stuff so so
growing up I was all about Sega
um and I'm aware I'm saying that wrong
everyone gives me enough crap on yeah
good
um
with the Mega Drive which you guys had
as the Genesis right in Europe and
Australia it was the Mega Drive that's
sort of when I was introduced to console
Wars God
because most of my friends had Super
Nintendo songs you did had a bigger drug
you know I I've told this story before
but I remember you know I was a big
Street Fighter fan
and I just remember wanting Street
Fighter at home so so much and then of
course as many of us would know Street
Fighter was announced as a Super
Nintendo exclusive no I'm the exclusive
what time exclusive yeah
yes but I broke your heart I didn't know
about that concept back in yeah 92 we
just saw that all that was coming out on
was Super Nintendo and I remember one of
my best mates at the time
he was staying over at my house for
flipping through a gaming magazine he
was a Super Nintendo guy and as we're
flipping through there was a two-page ad
for Street Fighter on
Super Nintendo we've shown the peak
we've we found it and we've shown it on
our show and it's just
it's basically just a picture of this
guy's eyes and a little screenshot of
Street Fighter and it just says
Street Fighter on Super Nintendo you
know Mega Drive owners dream on oh
I had the slander for
the other Point world I never noticed it
wasn't over here
he's just grabbed this magazine turned
it around in my face
this is too much so yeah when Street
Fighter 2 Champion Edition finally came
to the Mega Drive that was like one of
the happiest days in my life and there
was my mum paying 120 Australians wow
it's funny people talk about how
expensive gaming is now it was more
about that it was next level back then
it was just
and you were just you adjust those
prices for inflation yeah
that's how expensive gaming was back
then
um so yeah
the console that sort of said I was a
Sega Fanboy growing up the console that
got me to realize I'm missing out on too
much elsewhere which one was the
Nintendo 64. hmm so anytime I used to go
to my best man's house I mean became my
best man he was a Nintendo guy so my
exposure to Nintendo was through his NES
through his snazz and 364 and I remember
any time he'd have a sleepover 64 was
out GoldenEye Mario Kart
um all split screen yeah
four controllers what controllers
none of us want to split screen on a
65-inch OLED right now yeah we want our
own screen
back then you will never know these days
that
that's why probably so many people have
glasses now
[Laughter]
screens on 68 centimeters
that was a lounge room TV back then 68
centimeters
if you were Rich maybe you had an 80
centimeter no he's right and we were
four players to put screen together
your screen was this big like my iPhone
was probably a bigger screen than the
split screen I had on the TV somebody
said four plus screen on a 15 inch
yeah remember us putting that money
together to buy that 21 inches
21 inch yeah continue dick you're right
we were splitting screens on that
and I just remember playing GoldenEye
and Mario cut I'm like oh my God these
games are so good like I have to gotta
play 64. so yeah nice after that that
was like I was like okay I gotta buy
everything now you know so you know I
went back later and bought a PlayStation
one which I had skipped got the PS2 and
so on and so forth I mean Sega was still
ultimately in my heart Dreamcast for me
is still the greatest
console ever whoa but but that was
because I was also still an arcade gamer
probably
almost into my 20s I love the arcade
love
they're having all those arcade ports
yes arcade perfect perfect ports yeah at
home was like
what's the next level like I still
remember that they so
EB used to do like preview nights down
here oh nice and I remember in 99 they
did a preview night for the Dreamcast oh
yeah I remember going there just
everyone's Jaws were on the floor seeing
Soul Calibur oh my God Sonic Adventure
everyone is watching that Orca run where
the orcas are coming through Sonic and
like no one could believe I mean we all
see that now like if you look at it
today it's like obviously aged a bit but
yeah back in 99 you're just like what
the hell am I seeing right now it's just
ah Peter Moore
I feel like I feel like I don't know I
don't know if kids will have that kind
of EX because look at like I my son is
seven my daughter is 11.
they played Roblox and Minecraft and yep
but but games look so good for them now
that I don't know if they'll ever have
that appreciate moment that we all had
when we transitioned yeah 8-bit 16-bit
you know I don't know if they'll ever
get that it was a jump
every generation it was a discernible
jump like this when we went from 8-bit
to 16 bit it was mind-blowing we went
from 16-bit to 32-bit you could not stop
us when we got to 64-bit we thought we
was the cream of the crop and then that
3DO hit and then you know prices went
with it but um no you're right it's a
huge jump every generation I don't think
it's that much of a huge jump now in
terms of Generation
Um because you know 360 games still hold
up PlayStation 3 games still hold up
PlayStation 4 games hold up to
PlayStation 5. and so on I think our
leaps is more in
the architecture of the build the AI of
the computer uh the interface and how we
interface with it uh but back then there
was so much Headroom in what we can do
you know and get to you know now we're
hitting the ceiling I do think that we
have came to a certain cap when it comes
to Graphics like obviously there is
still I would say some room for
improvement but I do feel like you know
but what it's not gonna matter anymore
on the way the game looks because I feel
like the majority of the games are going
to look good especially in AAA
development yeah they're going to start
changing how the game feels in place
other stuff too number good good point
as far as the um the Dreamcast and like
you said that launch and and I just
remember how amazing that launch lineup
was like it was Raiders
Untouchable yes Untouchable continue
nothing nothing will ever come closer
it's funny because you're you're
mentioning getting earlier your son
wanting the PS5 my seven-year-old's
exactly the same he works in PS5 so
believe it or not he has started saving
up okay 600 bucks he's got a target of
600 bucks to save up okay
him hurry up because Jim I heard Jim is
about to raise the price
wow he's like I forgot they changed the
price you know it is like when you're an
American gamer we live in our own bubble
and we forget how it affects all the
other countries other regions and
literally you know special Nick is in
the region where it's affected like well
yeah quick Sidetrack bar
um like how was that received like like
I mean what was the consensus or what
for the most part people just grumbled
it was all right we'll still deal with
it like I just I'm curious about that I
know we're going off tangent uh the the
jump wasn't huge he was like 50 bucks
okay so it was it was about that in
every region 50 bucks but that's huge
yeah but but I find fifty dollars is
seen very differently depending on where
you're from yeah yeah like 50 is huge
for a kid for eight-year-old kid who has
a goal or 600. you understand this this
is where I yell at this is my my problem
kid has a goal right he's saving his
money up to but this is what the parent
come and after the fact and you don't
have to teach them the hot lessons of
life but listen you made it up here I
got you the rest of the way don't worry
about it um and we get you a game but
for him to see the price and in his
heart he you know he got his six could
you imagine he got a six and he's like
Dad he's taking me down to the store and
you get down there and it's fifty
dollars more you know that's kind of
crazy you know because he set a goal and
he's trying to achieve that goal but go
on uh I apologize for my team no that's
okay I don't know that's fine
um so yeah he he has his goal now he's
got his heart set on getting the PS5 but
it's funny I noticed when he jumps on
mine and he's playing like
I I look I'm I'm not gonna assume that
my experience was the same as everyone
else's but I I know with most kids back
then the first thing we do when we see a
game a new game is oh my god look how
good it looks and obviously as those
leaps came we'd be like oh my God look
at what it looks I find with kids now
that they don't even worry about how a
game looks it doesn't even register with
them because like I said they play junk
like Roblox Roblox
like my son is obsessed with Astro yeah
he just plays it like but now when I
first saw Astro one of the first things
I noticed was just how clean and
Polished and beautiful it looked he
doesn't even that doesn't yep that's a
good point just that it's a good point
just
plays the game and ah that looks like
that that thing that happened is cool
and that thing that happened is cool and
oh my controller is shaking bye-bye and
it's doing this and it's doing that
um it's it's just funny as how different
it is for them yes versus how it was for
us maybe it's because we came from Atari
which was just a few blocks on the
screen
did then Master System Nest which was a
few more colors a few more blocks on the
screen
because I don't think they had that
experience growing up for them so my son
is seven which means when he could
recognize what a video game was it
already looked like God of War yeah it
already looked like phenomenal it
already yeah they already had those
unbelievable visuals so they they don't
know what it is to come from
looking at blocks on the screen real
blocks it's a fantastic
and plus also we were roomed up into the
the tech like we get a magazine like you
said you read the magazine we were so
like we'll get the magazine and we'll
read about it we'll read about everyone
turbo Graphics
new cards and then when we got a chance
to see it in action our anticipation was
building up until we got a chance to see
it in action and it was really lived up
to our expectations of the next thing
yeah you know I find that today
different experience it is because I
found it today a lot of kids uh like
love of games is very game specific
right it's very sick it's not I love
games in general like my nephew doesn't
want to go to a Gaming website and read
everything that's on the website like we
read those magazines back in the day he
cares about uh fortnite Minecraft
Pokemon that's what he cares about yeah
nothing every anything else out of that
purview it's like whatever Tim doesn't
matter at all yeah
yeah yeah no that's okay
um and yeah I just and I think in the
long term it's probably a good thing
that they're the way they are like now
when I show them
the older stuff that I used to play they
don't have that reaction that I was
expecting the action the reaction I was
expecting was oh god look how this looks
but they don't they don't care they just
see it as a game it was a game another
game which I think again in the long run
is good it's a good thing like
I think that's why Indie Games Thrive so
much now
because our grade of appreciation for
Indies you know allows us to see India
in a different Act
these kids now
indie game is just a game if it's a good
game it doesn't matter because my son
plays terrania and if anybody seems
yeah I'm like what the hell is that and
I came from blocks on the screen but um
he's playing it with such hype like I'm
running upstairs I just got the sword
and I'm doing this thing and I'm like
well what are you playing and I get
upstairs and I'm like this guy's playing
this is such a good time and I'm like
okay so really for this generation it's
really about the game whatever they fall
in love
my daughter played unpacking and she
loved it yeah oh wow
that's just that's basically almost 16
bit pixel style and she loved it she did
the what it looked like didn't register
with her it was just yeah she saw that
game thought it was cool and played it
yeah definitely um
yeah yeah I don't know I think in the
long run it's a good thing yes I don't I
don't know I don't think our kids
will grow up as the console Warriors we
all were growing up I don't think so
either
um
probably because of us probably because
of that it's like I didn't have exposure
like video games are such a normal part
of life now right yeah
back then they weren't at all they were
very much a
not underground's not the right word
yeah it was it was because you were no
boys uh you were a child uh grow up you
know you know
yeah
a huge stigma yeah yeah it's so so I
think in the long run it'll be a good
thing that they're growing up
the way they're growing up
um like you said earlier King I I don't
influence my son in terms of because
he's got a series s he's got a a switch
and now he wants a PS5
[Music]
um so I've said to him if you want one
you're getting money for Christmas you
get money for your birthday my wife's
telling him do chores do this
save up and get it right right now he
plays mine like the the most excited I
saw him at Christmas was my parents
getting him his own dual sense hmm so he
doesn't have the console but he is ready
Jewel sense and he's synced it to mine
and that's his controller
plays the PS5 with it
and yeah it's just I find that
interesting how different they are and
they will be to what we were no it's
just because of that shift in how games
are now compared to when we were kids
absolutely
um
but that no no I'm just gonna say I've
realized like I'm that's totally
um but yes I've just always after the 64
I just said no I there's too many
amazing games to miss out on so I went I
still obviously had my preferences
um I found as I got older I get a lot of
crap for this let's go in the in the
Discord and stuff but
I found as I got older though because I
started to own every console this is
going to sound very weird and I don't
know a better way to say it it's
probably less but I but I found as I got
older
that the games themselves became a less
important factor in where I
wear my main platform was because in my
mind pretty much every console has games
with play of course even the worst
selling consoles ever like I had a 3DO I
had a Jaguar like
oh my God to check your Jesus
and then Trevor mcfer I still don't know
how that control will works yeah right
you have to flush the toilet and then
yeah
they was trying to keep up with you
don't remember in the coleco vision
where you uh put the overlay in and it
turned the control into something
different yes yes right so that concept
remember this is the uh um the the the
maker of the Atari he's still
remembering how ColecoVision came in and
kind of cleaned this clock on certain
things our controller he's still
battling ColecoVision
he wants to Overlay because the overlay
worked great with Aliens versus Predator
when when implemented properly that
overlay worked well you had a whole
bunch of buttons that looked like a
telephone and you were able to hit uh
certain buttons certain things I'm
trying to remember they uh on an old
sitcom when I was growing up called
Drake and Josh there was this console
that people always made fun of like Chad
I'm sure someone in there remembers with
that it was like a cube what what was it
so what did this chat remembers no no
the GameCube this thing doesn't exist
it's not right but no it's not rich
can't remember what it was called they
probably got like a play Cube or
something like that it was like green or
something like that like it was a cube
like a literally Cube and they and I
remember they made a show on Drake and
Josh where this thing was the game
sphere that's the games
it was it was like the hardest thing to
find on that episode like and they they
were going crazy trying to find it it
was hilarious are you South Park
no no
yeah yeah it was a show called something
South Park had almost the exact same
thing where the kids were like after the
I think it was called the okama game
sphere
yeah Frank cuss in a common games for me
with cell phone yeah
that's hilarious it's spherical
all right so you Jaguar let's keep going
keep going
oh yes the the controller I mean King
was saying it was just I don't know how
many of you in chat or whatever had one
but it it had just rows of buttons it's
kind of comfortable in your hand though
oh my God the buttons it was just crazy
[Laughter]
generation I don't like to remember
oh yeah
um
yeah I just so that so that was the
moment the 64 was the moment where I
said I've got to have everything you
know so I was there for the PS2 day one
PS you know the PS3 was 999 in Australia
sale prices
I I bought the PS3 almost at launch I
didn't I wasn't there day one I was
there a few months later because I'm
like you know what God of War 3 is
coming
and remember launch PS3s so Americans
were very lucky in that your launch PS3s
could play PS1 and PS2 yeah
in in Europe and Australia the launch
PS3s could play PS1 and PS2 games but
with PS2 games it was via emulation it
was like a software emulation
yeah they went emulation on it they took
the chip out remember they had the whole
motherboard and that's why I called so
much they had the whole motherboard in
for the players too inside the PS3 these
guys said the hell with that it's
costing us too much money they took it
out and then you would play play as two
games through emulation
so it wasn't 100 compatibility like
yours was right yeah they gave you a
list of what games was compatible yes
they have Linux in it
they went through all that trouble to
make sure that you know that was factors
compatible and they're like let's change
it
because they changed the software and
completely deleted it yeah yep continued
it they did that was devastating
um
but yeah um and then that's it I've just
been with everything ever since
um and now I just remember in my train
of thought let's go
um as I got older the the games
themselves became
less important because I felt everything
had great games worth playing so I
started to look at the platform itself
um
now the PS3 was probably my favorite
PlayStation because I think that was the
one time Sony had like a real ecosystem
going mm-hmm
when they had this PlayStation Home
yep and you had crossed by and you had
cross save with a lot of the games
um
I always loved I still have a PS3 back
here absolutely
um but then I sort of
Xbox now again I get a lot of crap for
the fact that I don't like a lot of Xbox
games
[Laughter]
I just like the Xbox platform and what
it does I like I love that
is you know you buy a game and it's on
your PC and you've got
proper backwards compatibility all the
way back that's a thing of the past now
right now the last console to do it was
the launch PS3
because many many forget that the 360
wasn't properly backwards compatible
with you correct software correct but no
it was that was Hardware remember that
was Nvidia
and they had went from Nvidia to uh yes
off-the-shelf uh Parts you don't
remember
yes yeah so yeah it was different
architecture inside the PlayStation was
just smart they just said hey we're
gonna put a whole PS2
and you guys because the PS2 could play
PS1 games
so you had the whole back compat all the
way in one box that's yeah see
people don't understand that's what I
love PlayStation about like those the
head of PlayStation then it was so
aggressive they were so a bold in their
stance and they were really giving you
more in the Box than what the I mean the
Box costs more right the price point
they sold it and I know people are
saying 700 King listen to me
that's seven hundred dollars in the Box
you had a PlayStation one PlayStation 2
and a PlayStation 3 in that box right so
you can just sell your old consoles but
keep your games yep that was what I
loved about that was perfect right then
you then you had that and then that was
the box that had Blu-ray yes Blu-ray was
that was the first time we had high
definition movies right out the box it
was the cheapest one but it was probably
the best
you know it was DVD was the um
Blu-ray right that's why you had to get
another job
I mean but again in the Box you had
Blu-ray Playstation three yeah it was
the best thing
it made no sense to get a standalone
Blu-ray player people
PS3 factual yes right so they gave you
all of that in the Box they were hella
aggressive in their approach in their
stance and they always pushed the
envelope that's my Sony that was Peak
Sony for me yeah same here I'm sorry
but that that's what I love the better
and I loved that it was this box that
just did everything it even people
forget the launch units had like all the
different
uh memory card race you remember that so
I could read Sony's memories
everything super audio CD player yeah
they just they just threw everything
into it it was a genius of a box
everything yes it was I I loved it I was
gutted mine mine was starting to show
signs of the GPU dying yeah
so I was gutted that I I couldn't get it
fixed so I'm like before this thing dies
I think I'm gonna need to sell it
because mine still had
you did the EB Games
make sure it worked a couple times
right there Gamers know about that
you're like yo I just need the street to
turn on it just work one time one time
when I trade you in oh I was lucky I was
good at making my stuff still look brand
new so the guy that bought it yeah
he was like yeah no it works let me see
there it is you see and he knew if he
held this button to hold it uh the train
shout out to that dude that didn't know
I hopefully it's still going on him
because it had other OS still on it I
still had Linux on mine when I sold it
um so I sold it for a lot of money
because it's it was the backwards
compatible one it was the one that had
the other OS yeah sort of stuff yes
I like you more Nick I like you
know it kills that two bundle after that
[Laughter]
I think I I reckon I ended up owning
like across the period I think I ended
up earning like four or five different
PS3s like I've got I've got two of them
at the moment I've got a silver one and
I've got a black one
um yeah I got big into the limited
edition consoles so like have you ever
had a um Panasonic GameCube
no but I wanted one of them so Nick let
me tell you all right so this is my hunt
of the of the Panasonic GameCube me and
me and Rick rested that Rick saw one and
Rick was like yo I'm gonna go get it
I had to beat this guy to it so I ran
downtown to Elizabeth Street and it was
an absorbitant amount of money but a
game modded already right so okay I was
like listen I'm gonna pay this money I
got it got it at home uh I didn't tell
him that I had it yet he got his and was
like yo you want to come over and check
it out I said yes of course I got over
there
his joint wasn't modded so he had you
know all the initialness and all that
other ones on the screen I was like oh
that's nice that's nice so he comes over
to my house right because you know we
trade TVs he's like oh why didn't you
tell me you got it I said yeah but I got
the special edition he's like yes the
penis I said no no check it out I went
and put my American disc right aside
it came up in English
yes he had blood in his nose
he's like hey you want to sell that over
here
that thing I sold that
um when I had to get my 3D oh I think
that went for my 3DO I think so but it
was something it was probably a couple
of uh Neo Geo cartridges or something
like that well see I never had the Neo
Geo that was another console I always
wanted I'm a joke
in Australia that was like a thousand
dollars or more like in like 92 and like
that's the same
processing amount of money
the way you guys talk about the Neo Geo
I don't think it exists I think you guys
I think the unicorns
it's been a long gold troll to convince
adding something his existence whatever
I actually see these pictures of it I
got the Neo Geo gold up here yeah
Photoshop the cartridges uh like the
the thing with the Neo Geo was the
cartridges were the actual arcade board
yes that's why the cartridge was I speak
you know like I'm sure I'm sure when you
guys had your meeting this morning to
explain how to explain it to me that's
what you guys are crazy
250 a cartridge and uh yeah it was
definitely same exact thing you got
there the same exact thing you got now
the arcade boys allowed you to take your
was it memory thing and you could oh
that's when they knew your wallet was
good yeah oh yeah oh yeah
tremendously tremendous history I love
it yeah
yeah I know I feel like I've been
ranting on a business I started on the
track and then I do this on our show I
start on a track and then I yeah every
week don't worry about that
I got I got into limited edition
consoles big time like I had I think I
had like again over the journey I had
like 10 360s damn I just because they
had the most limited editions oh see
through so many limitations
um you know I saw the there was the
black Modern Warfare 2 ones forget that
the red Resident Evil 5 once I was like
oh my God the Gears of War one yeah I
think that was the one I didn't get I
got it upstairs
I think you're eventually
the series X have a a decent amount
because I feel like the only reason they
haven't really capitalized on that is
because of the shortage they don't want
to like waste the uh the stock they had
on something else and like hold it back
for this particular launch because if
you think about like the show the series
that should be easy to to oh yeah to do
that kind of stuff with so no absolutely
I've got the Halo one I've got the HALO
Series I was so tempted we was live with
it together I think I went out yeah
shout out to them like they did their
thing on that man though so you went
down a slippery slope of the consoles
and all that yeah oh yeah I had I had
the the um Halo 3 one that ugly green
yeah
I sold it last year for 500 Australian
and it still had the blades on it wow
so when I sold it on eBay I took a photo
saying look this is still got the plates
and that's all very fast yeah they want
that
um I got the Star Wars the R2D2 oh yeah
the blades on my 360 I guess we'll go
upstairs too yeah
he's really Nick
I think the only 360 I've got left now
is the Halo reach one that's silver that
was beautiful Hawaiian silver Halo reach
one yeah nice clean it was clean we're
now my limited edition console thing is
more with switches now I can't stop
buying Nintendo switches as soon as they
release a new all four of my switches
and they're not all mine it's one for
each
yeah
all the castles I love it though all
four so my son my my son has the all red
Mario one oh
my daughter has the Animal Crossing one
my wife says the fortnite one okay
and mine is the Splatoon 3 only fire
five okay
four of them good you and King should
have attended therapy yeah these two no
no
he said it was four members of his house
and he made sure they all felt special
that is though I I respect that listen
man ah look I've still got my uh my
Pokemon
Nintendo 64 the half blue half yellow
one yeah
and it's got the VHS tape of the movie
with it still in the box oh oh yeah wow
that's the one that has the button of um
of the Pokeball right as a Pokeball
somewhere on it right
again the Australian version
to the American version the American
version had Pikachu on the it's like
this molded theme yes you're right the
button where the Australian one just
looked like a straight up 64. the bottom
half was yellow the top half was blue
and it had stickers on it oh like these
decal sticker things gotcha good
question that'll be on this this path
because you you educated yes for us I
keep remembering it's not a one-to-one
thing with the American version and the
Australian version is what is the
American version of maybe a console
since you you you're kind of sore with
this that you wish came to Australia
that never came that you're like damn we
didn't get that one oh
um there was one I was thinking about
actually there was a PlayStation I think
there was a place Spiderman Three there
was a PlayStation 3. now we got I think
we've got the Spider-Man one here there
was a PlayStation 3 that we never got oh
uh oh God which one was it probably the
final one there's one of them I think it
was either Dragon Quest or Final Fantasy
it was one of those PlayStations I
wasn't into the game itself but the
console was stunning it was probably
their final fantasy that Final Fantasy
one was incredible
lightning on it yeah I think I could not
I could not get that one to save my life
I tried that and that Spider-Man
PlayStation 4. I could not get them
that's because they only printed like
eight of those things ain't nobody
buying the lightning yeah okay
um when Nintendo's very good to us we
get stuff you guys don't get oh flip it
yeah tell us give us one give us give a
couple because I think because Nintendo
has a headquarters down here in
Melbourne no
I think we this like I've got mates on
Twitter that are from the US and I send
them stuff because they like bro we can
get all this cool stuff you guys don't
get what the E that rewards shop and
yeah Australia is quite good with
Nintendo stuff less great with
PlayStation stuff and Xbox is just Xbox
has always been I guess Global rights
that kind of thing there's the only
thing we miss out on with Xbox is
whenever they do those bloody Twitter
competitions yes they retweet to get
this awesome Pac-Man series
always for the I read the rules and it's
always for the US and Canada that's a
good point man I feel you brother I feel
you I don't even think about that thing
like when my son saw that Pac-Man Series
S he's like
what's good I see little man on Deck I
need little man with the Pac-Man out
what's up I I do feel like Americans
take that for granted too you do take
that for granted if you really think
about it like
it's a logistical nightmare no it is
because uh when I had to shift early on
we will print up our own shirts and ship
them out
shout out to mods in Poland I had to
ship out a shirt to him it was basically
shipping it for free right because you
know the the the the the customs and all
that stuff costs it was whatever
um but you have to fill out an
international form
and an international form you have to
declare items you have to do all this
stuff and you have to go through this
there's a very strict regulations uh
going from country to Country and you
know he was over there in Poland and I
remember sending it to him I felt happy
that somebody in Poland was uh you know
even you know buying something from us
because they're so happy because it
finally was over I'm sorry no but I'm
like man if we get 10 to 15 people from
Poland and I'm down here filling it out
I was holding up the line I didn't know
so I understand
I totally get it I've got shout out to
my friend
um Chris zedox uh he's in our Discord he
actually
I don't think you'll mind telling the
story
because of our Discord uh you know we've
told people Phil is in that discourse
it's a very prestigious very prestigious
Discord and through all the Microsoft
staff that are in that Discord Chris you
know one day he thanked me because he
got a job at Microsoft India works at
Microsoft
the connections in that Discord and
Chris you know the the and you know like
you guys are mentioning how you forget
that the rest of the world doesn't
always get what you guys get you know
design Labs that just came to Australia
now
Australia so I wanted to get my kids
design Labs control as well before we
got them so I was doing that through
Chris because when you were saying King
how you were sending those that stuff to
the guy in Poland it reminded me like
Chris
he so I put together the the combination
I wanted no you log on to the site do
the controller I'd transfer him the
money and he'd send it down from the US
yeah every time that those two con and
with my son's one it was annoying
because I just organized his controller
250 Australian I think 250 or 300 I paid
because you guys only paid like what was
it what was it what is it for the design
labs for you guys free no I went through
mine was free
your situation is much different than
others
yes but uh yeah I I can't remember off
top but it would definitely worked yeah
and with the shipping and everything and
I remember those boxes would come
covered in speaking of which he's in the
chat he says
he's like I'm here
brother we stitching
yeah
um you know he so I was very
appreciative of the fact that he was
going out of his way to go down to the
post office you know go through all the
hassle of sending something yes
internationally
and like three months
two months or three months after my
son's controller came they announced
design labs for Australia
there's no way no of course though
yeah it just it just reminded me that
Chris has always done that
he good he said I don't mind you sharing
it we good we good okay cool the statues
limitations I didn't think he I didn't
think he would mind but I I took a
gamble anyway
but yeah so I honestly like I feel like
I've been talking for so long now I've
completely forgotten
we got to you collecting and now we're
gonna make the transitions
no tremendous history and again that's
just I love how you broke down the
differences you know what I'm saying
from from a region standpoint I do want
to get into like King was saying as far
as your journey in the content creation
because you know your story is unique I
know I've heard it but for all for the
people in the realm that are not
familiar with you like tell us about
like that transition from you know kind
of being a gamer and then saying all
right I want to kind of get into content
creation and this gaming Forum scene
like how does this whole thing happen
yeah okay so I mean I I reckon this
story is a bit boring but it wasn't so
much content creation so I assume many
of you will be aware of the The
Unofficial PlayStation Forum Etc
and uh
anyone who was a member of that Forum
will know that if you weren't a fan of
PlayStation the experience of using that
Forum was less than ideal
[Laughter]
and we had we had developed there was a
group of us in it Twitter group chat
from that Forum because we just couldn't
because it was so
because it was so unusable on that Forum
like any anyone who knows if you try to
make like an Xbox thread or try to talk
about Xbox it just used to get
trolled into a blue
so we created you can talk about what
you were to talk about
to continue we we so we had a group
Twitter DM that we used to just chat
about games and Xbox and we used to
complain about what was going on on the
Forum
one of the guys in there was like have
you guys heard of Discord
like no what the hell is this guy this
is like 2018.
this other thing where we can chat it's
a bit better than Twitter DMS blah blah
so he creates the Xbox here at Discord
because we were part of the Xbox era on
resettera community
creates the Discord
and you know we all we start adding
people because more and more people were
getting very frustrated with that Forum
so just more and more people we're
joining this Discord
and after a while the guy that started
it handed it over to me I think it was
about six months in
and I started going out of my way to get
the
uh developers and the journalists and
all that sort of stuff into the Discord
because I'm at the time I was still a
little bit of a celeb Hall
so I wanted to get all of their mean
and I I need it because I started to get
so many of those developers and stuff in
I wanted to keep the Discord small okay
um and after a while of running that
I thought to myself I kept asking
everyone in there I was like oh I've
always sort of wanted to do a podcast
because we talked we talk so much about
this stuff I'm like why don't we just
why don't we just stuff around and we'll
like start a podcast and everyone's like
oh yeah maybe we'll see how we go
one day someone reached out to me and
said look there's a dude who's still on
reset but he's not in the Discord and
he's talking about starting an Xbox
podcast
and I'm like oh okay so I reached out to
him we got him into this Garden that's
sick
and we were chatting back and forth like
why don't we start a podcast well like
okay now if you go and watch those if
you go and watch those earlier episodes
the podcast me attic know about some
early days right
I don't quite have the same production
yeah
we all had to start Subway that's right
so we started them on Discord and just
to clarify you you can't find all this
don't go look my heart
I'm sorry I'm sorry continue yeah that's
okay
um yeah they're the production value is
less than Stella to say the least and
you know we were still discovering how
to sort of do it like
so we started them in Discord but then
we found there was a lot of lag issues
because I was over in Australia
UK and and figments who we had on at the
start was in the US
um and then we we switched over to Skype
oh we did that too
I thought about the Skype things
continue we switched over to Skype
because Skype had ndi which which made
it easier to put everything together but
then even
like even
Skype had its lag issues and all that
sort of stuff and then you know we
eventually moved to stream yard and all
that sort of stuff but you know I
remember saying to John when we first
started it like again I I used to listen
to a handful of Xbox podcasts before we
started ours and I just
all I remember was the ones I dropped
off were the ones that
used to skip a lot of episodes because
for whatever reason they just couldn't
do it consistency or whatever and I said
to John I said look man if we start this
gotta do it I'm not skipping an
episode's goal talking
one single episode so we so we started
fortnightly because we we both were very
busy families this that the other were
like every two weeks is doable
and after a while
as as we grew and grew we were sort of
stagnating a bit and rammed we developed
a friendship with
I don't like him anymore
you guys need to go you need to go
weekly
um
it's gonna be tricky it's like now
you've got to go weekly if you want to
grow you've got to go weekly oh my God
so we're going back and forth we're like
do we go weekly do we go weekly and I
said to John again I'm like but if we go
weekly
missing an episode I'm not missing a
show if we do it anyway we eventually
pulled the trigger on going weekly we
pulled the trigger on going live because
we weren't live for like the first
year I think okay we did pre-record it
and then we put the episode together and
splice and these induction values
brother the production values yeah
production value yeah reproduction
[Laughter]
um and yeah but I said to John when we
first started I said I have one goal
just one I don't know when it's gonna
happen but I have one goal we've got to
get Phil on oh perfect we've got to get
Phil on
because you led perfect ly into my next
question Okay so
you start the podcast again I I love
what you said about you know kind of
getting your bearings getting that
Cadence getting that consistency get
into a flow you're starting to build
slowly so I'm a little stagnation here
we won't go through it and then you
start there you get the stage advice you
know what I'm saying for Ram now again I
got a shout out because to me you know
obviously I've seen you guys for a while
but we gotta talk about This Magic
Moment you know what I'm saying now I've
been in that Discord and just for the
record y'all Xbox ever Discord is the
who's who of gaming in this Discord it
is a very prestigious shout out to my
man Christmas I've been near a lot of
people up in there but for me seeing
that magic moment because you had two me
you had two before that was the book
project what I would have shout you out
five years yeah you have 20 years of
Xbox celebrating Universe it's coming
it's still covered you all should have
got your digital one by now but the the
actual book is very very soon it's right
and then
episode Xbox error episode 100 the Magic
Moment Community comes you did a video
for that didn't you yeah yeah
so Xbox ever some love and then the
whole Community comes through and you
have Phil
okay we gotta do the full name we gotta
do the full name Phil Dominus Maximus
are really expensive first of his name
comes on I gotta say I gotta say
Lord the special day I've never seen a
permanent smile on a man from eating
here during the whole podcast
you was you was in it the glow was there
tell us about the Magic Moment sir yeah
it was it's funny I'm wondering if I
should tell this story yes I should
break
I may have upset
the Xbox PR a little bit
of script
no oh no no no we weren't gonna do that
okay look we're not we're not IGN we're
not kind of funny we're not we're not
ILP we're not
people used to say to us get this person
on get this person I'm like it's not
dead
yeah we can't just walk up to whoever we
like and go hey see you on the show next
week
it doesn't work like that for us I I
have to harass people like I I hunt
people down like even the process
getting filled like I you know I was
like how do I reach out to Phil like I
have no idea so I just took a shot and
sent him a message on Xbox Live and he
replied
that's Lord addict energy I love this
that's attic energy
I have never I have never went to Xbox
Live yet now I've harassed on emails
yeah yeah by the way everyone in the
chat man you know go over there and tag
cliff on on Twitter and say you want
them on IOP everyone in the chat go to
Twitter right now tag clip Lucy on all
of us and say you want him in the
podcast
trying to get Cliff as well yeah some of
them are unicorns to get continue yeah
yeah oh my God I keep replying to him on
Twitter saying hey jump on and the dude
doesn't even acknowledge like I'm gonna
know how I'm gonna get this guy
he was like I do have a book he's like I
got a book
Breakers
that's gonna be a short challenge
so you run down
yes and I was shocked like I wasn't
expecting a reply because I mean we I
talked about this with Phil on the show
itself I was like I
I guess because I okay so before anyone
who's used stream yard before you go
live you could just sit there and chat
you know what's like a Lobby yes and
Phil is an amazingly nice person yes
and we were just chatting with him and
all three of us were freaking out a
little bit that we were just
a dear [__] Phil and he was just
talking to us like a regular person
and I said to him before we went live I
said look Phil I'm gonna run things by
you and you tell me what professional
what you don't want me to talk about
please
and I said because you know I was going
to tell the story about how all this
just started with an Xbox Live DM but I
don't want to say that publicly in case
you now get spammed with Xbox Live
messages because people might think
you're just gonna reply to all right
everybody go dig that's the new hospital
now get him yeah I I just worked under
the assumption that
I got lucky run maybe I dm'd you at the
right time when you were online and you
happened to see the message and blah
blah blah
he's like Nana don't go for it that's
fine I'm like okay so I I don't know if
he got spammed after that but I told
that story
but he didn't join the Discord straight
away he took that's right if I should
tell this story
let's go let's go let's go let's get it
all out I'm gonna tell it okay that's
how you get so much trouble let's go you
know the other the other voice on his
other shoulder was like that boy
have just through doing all this stuff
I've learned to harass people and I say
that in the nicest possible way attic
techno like because Phil wasn't joining
I don't already do that I wanted to join
like I'm not gonna let this go I'm
wanting to join the Discord so I just
dropped him a message every now and
again saying hey that the invite is
still alive there you go and like
pressure
sometimes he'd reply sometimes he
wouldn't reply and it's weird so
believe it or not
this is what got him to join and I found
that very interesting at the time let's
go I got Nathan Vella from capybara at
the time he was at capybara games at the
time he's now with Annapurna absolutely
I got him in the server because I liked
capybara games yeah yeah
and I don't know what made me do it but
I messaged Phil so hey Phil
said but just Nathan capabara games just
joined he seems like a really nice guy
he just joined the Disco
still joined like three minutes later
after I sent that message
now of course at the time this was this
was Peak acquisition season oh I see
what we got
so I'm like
you would have better make sure
don't you worry let our man talk let him
cook
and there's Microsoft are having a look
at capybara games
Microsoft's having a look at capybara
games
now obviously nothing's happened since
then but that was just a thought that
was running through you're just making
sure he wasn't breaking any ndas
let's see what this dude's saying
he joined a Discord he didn't clear with
PR let's see what's going on in here and
I was like oh that's very very
interesting
um and I just he joined and everyone
exactly what like
who did that for you
once only posted once in that
and he tagged that he tagged that dude
and said keep your mouth shut
uh I think it was like a happy holidays
oh that's what's up messy she was just
saying happy holidays and hope you all
and have a safe yeah I've got it I've
got it somewhere I have to find it I'm
sure you're pinning it and it's just
spammed to be full of different emojis
there's so many of them
oh yeah
um and then we got him to join the Forum
as well so he's joined the Forum and
he's posted
speaking speaking of Reggie is who I
want on the show yes sir
that's another one who's very very yeah
oh Reggie's hard to get oh yeah let me
tell you right now even a person he's
hard to talk to like he'll be talking to
you while moving away from you like
crazy Barry Sanders let me tell you I
got it Bill forgive me the most gangster
thing I feel well he's I was out in Pax
West you know he was running my
cameraman situation while I was dolo
because the Lords didn't come out for
that trip and we ran into him so Reggie
pulled that move so their bill blocked
him and was like yeah my man want to
speak to you Lord Cognito order so he
had to talk and we was like yeah that
was the most shout out to build I love
you bro that was hilarious but he did
give us a few minutes and it was like
but yeah I'ma tell you right now Reggie
hard the cat the last of the registry
story best move he got the best move and
also he got goons on Deck sometimes yeah
award show you know it was funny though
he he escorted him in after he had come
yeah he had come in and walked out but
he's not that like he's a he's like he's
like a media dude yeah no he's gonna do
but sometimes it'd be the Train the
goons yeah yeah so don't get too close
don't get too aggressive
Reggie's from the box
pull up roll already
that's true Reggie Reggie is looks like
you can take care
so and he got people to take care of us
just say some some advice some Sage
advice if you run okay the only way I
could think of I emailed Denny Pena yes
okay
because I know he had had him yes
dude I got a Reggie interview yes yes so
I emailed Denny being like hi Danny my
name's Nick
I noticed he had Reggie on
maybe it went to the junk folder I don't
know
um
yeah so now now that we got Phil on I
saw zdocs mention it in the chat because
he knows who my next goal is and I don't
think it's gonna happen but I'm gonna
have I've already shot my shot the other
day so I got Phil on my next Target is
Henry Campbell oh okay are we doing that
I want soup I want Superman
I don't know why the the energy he gives
out I feel like if you could actually
get it like if he went to like an E3 or
something for like a like a job he's
doing and you asked him I I honestly
feel like he would do it just the energy
he throws out yeah he's uh just about to
see him in person that's what it's about
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh I was just at
Madame two swords in Sydney and they had
Superman there I saw you with the
picture yeah a helico I was like I've
got to take a picture with Henry Cavill
I don't care
I can't
um so and again he's another one of
those guys he's not on anything yeah
yeah
I I literally just sent him a message on
Instagram
you might have to look up who his
manager is yeah
oh
wow wow
that is true
wow right there
I looked up his management and I've sent
them an email and I did not hear back so
tell him that you that you're starting a
new universe
tell them that you're in talks with uh
some lawyers about to sue DC good
morning brother
maybe I'll tell him that I'll fund Man
of Steel too
you're not speaking to the Rock either
Tom you don't know what the Rock's
cooking
RNR slander
tremendous tremendous moments brother
and to see the elevation and again the
clientele and who you're rubbing
shoulders with it's just been absolutely
amazing I did want to give you your
props on that because that was truly
important for the culture and keep doing
your thing on that and then um quick
question that being addict always asks
yes how did Lord dick and Xbox ever find
out about IOP was the first time you
heard IOP we always have to ask this
question
oh God uh it determines our marketing if
we change yeah we need to improve things
oh how did I I God I'm trying to
remember because again when you
I found joking going on wandering Dutch
oh really yep that's what's up because
um it was like a tweet out and then it
said you know I always heard about Xbox
ever and stuff like that and just like
you know Cog I mean I call uh uh
Sovereign
King doesn't listen to podcasts so
um I looked over and I was like I
noticed that I think uh one of you was
following me and I was like oh man I
didn't follow back wait a second and I
followed back and I went to the the
website I said let me check the YouTube
I was like oh okay and it was through
wander and Dutch that I found you guys
for me I think it was the website shout
out to Chris he goes he thinks that you
guys probably heard about us through the
Discord we all talk about different
podcasts probably okay I would not be
surprised if that's what it was through
the Discord yeah and I think me and
Chris was on midweek mix-up
Twitter friends and then he invited me
to the Discord I was like Wow look who's
in here this is insane like all you know
all the cool people and developers and
stuff like that and then I think that's
what we kind of started first kind of
communicating yes and then we got you on
our show a while back that was quite a
while ago uh we got another Xbox error
one bad mother in there he said I was
telling you this is what IOP was awesome
shout out to my man one bad mothers
that's my guy that makes sense that
makes sense no doubt um because yeah
when you you know when you get into the
Xbox podcast scene specifically
um yeah you just sort of
discover each other you just sort of get
to know
you know that that was when I
that was when I obviously very stupidly
made that joke on Twitter about yeah
the Xbox podcast thing being like the
MCU yes
you upset we do Crossovers and we're all
friends
see the pro what I've learned being an
Australian doing a predominantly
American mm-hmm
odd cast scene because it is most of the
podcasts are American yeah
you learn things yes about
Americans you learn things about
britsular
our humor doesn't always translate the
same way yes
unless you know the person well unless
you know the person well and intimately
that humor often doesn't
translate
and that MCU joke where I called myself
Iron Man oh yeah it was bad oh wow they
want you behind me for some reason see
now now I understand I see because at
first I'm like I don't know why anybody
will be upset yeah with that thought
process because we all like the MCU and
there's a whole bunch of crossovers but
when you say that you're Iron Man
this is a fake thought that Iron Man
started the movie the dudes dudes got
their feelings
bricks down on oh okay I get it dude I
remember that I remember that distinctly
yeah that's a good one who's the first
one
for me it was more for me it was more
I've always loved Iron Man growing up I
was one of the only kids that liked Iron
Man when everyone else was Batman
Superman Spider-Man I was an Iron Man
kid though so I just always loved Iron
Man I kind of despised him as a kid
after I found out what his uh problems
were but that's neither here nor there
that's foreign
it rains like the same way
um I got you brother but yeah it's it's
good you get to know a lot of cool
people absolutely great Community love
the fact that you know we get the chance
to do these crossover episodes love the
history fantastic I've always wanted to
yeah I've always wanted to but it's hard
like again
and in fact like I said yeah I'm sorry
no I was gonna say like right now it's
Monday here yeah you're in the future
yeah just for everyone knows this man is
in the future so now salute how Monday
feels
well the reason so hey here and it's
Thursday I was gonna say when it's
Wednesday here and it's Thursday there
I'm gonna ask you what the what the Xbox
event was
get exclusive
um it normally I would be starting work
right now seven o'clock at seven o'clock
in the morning here so I would normally
be starting work so
being on your podcast is basically
impossible possible
we've tried it yeah we were like yeah we
we tried for so long to make it works
obviously yeah I was able to come on
your show but to do the opposite was
hard that's why I was so happy when you
said yo I got this month off you know
I'm gonna make this a whole month off
yeah that's dope I reached out I reached
I think I'll never go back to work now
so I wish that's it's the worst when you
have when you come off a vacation and
you got to go into work that first day
your body is so resistance impossible
[Music]
um
so yeah I sent messages to all the
people that had asked me I've got DMS
from back in May last year of people
saying hey we'd love to have you on the
show and I'm like it's gonna be real
tricky because you're on during my work
day
but I didn't forget any of them and as
soon as I knew I had January booked up
booked off I reached out to everyone and
I'm like okay if you still want me on
this is
yeah I mean anyone who has been watching
I've been oh you were making your run
you've been making your own brother I've
been doing it I've been doing so much
that's very nice of you because I get a
month off I'ma tell you dudes right now
anybody looking for me to podcast on my
month off
I think the difference is is he had a
month off and he knew this is the only
opportunity that's a beautiful person
absolutely so we do running on time a
little bit so I do whatever that's the
questions that we ask all the guests in
the realm I need Lord special Nick's top
five video games or franchises of all
time this is goat talk I want to know oh
my God your personal five I over the
years I've broken this list up into two
two lists there's my top five I guess
games of all time but I found that
there's other games that while
they're not the greatest games they're
games I keep going back to that's what
if that makes sense
so I've always told people I've got a
top five or top ten and then I've got a
top five or a top ten that I go back to
all the time so so my top five is like
fairly stock standard
it's hard to put them in order Ocarina
of Time
God of War 2005 God of War the good ones
oh wow you were kick in pocket
uh what are the other Halo Combat
Evolved
uh
uh Street Fighter 2.
and I'm trying to think what else what
would be the fifth game what would be
the fifth game
oh
God off the top of my head I'll throw
because again the order is hard I'll
throw in
probably Daytona USA
okay that's the arcades that's those
arcade routes coming out now I've also
got
games that while they're not maybe
all-time classics or those games that I
just listed for some reason I love them
so much and I keep going back to them
like
when a game I go back to all the time is
Super punchier oh yes we just have to
add a quick watch out like yeah just
played the original question why I know
most people turning off
try to reset most people consider okay I
will turn it off
most people consider the original punch
out the better one I don't know for some
reason I just always lean towards Super
Punch Out okay okay I always just lean
towards soup don't get me wrong all
three of them are amazing yes
but super is the one I keep going but I
replay it just all the time
um I mean obviously rocket League
because that's all I play
um
Titanfall
uh Titanfall is just oh so wait a second
you like Titanfall one over Titanfall
two oh it's not even close
in terms of the multiplayer yeah one
didn't have a campaign correct Titanfall
2's campaign is one of the greatest yes
shooter campaigns that's ever existed
right but you can't compare Titanfall
one to Titanfall 2 as a whole because
Titanfall 2 has a section that one
doesn't have correct but if I'm just
comparing
stuff to his test yeah yeah a lot of
people didn't like we thought that was
going to be it for for the Xbox One when
that game hit I brought that big titan
oh yeah I had the big box I said they
gonna push forward with this and bro
time for one I remember playing late
last night it was so good so good
continue
absolute perfection uh so yeah Super
Punch Out rocket League Titanfall
Donkey Kong Country
and Streets of Rage too all right so
it's the first Donkey Kong Country
yes the first one remember when oh God
remember when okay because there was
still 16-bit yeah and they went to
32-bit and they was talking all this
Nintendo went into their bag of tricks
and said nah this is what we do when we
do silicon graphic molding and Donkey
Kong Country came out I remember the
crowd going crazy at E3 this is when we
still got the the VHS
it was like oh my God we never see
anything it looked that bad
stunning yo I don't know what they doing
but they held off from going to 32. yeah
with that game absolutely and then you
already mentioned this already but we
gotta ask anyway for people to hear next
Molex favorite console of all time and
why
the Dreamcast whoa It's the Dreamcast
lazy like why why so confident why so
quick
oh like
again as an arcade gamer and a Sega kid
the Dreamcast was I guess the epitome of
everything like a culmination you know
even though the Sega Fanboy in me
I blinded myself and I saw those arcade
ports as better than they were on the
Master System the Mega Drive the Saturn
you know there's this story that my
brother always tells and I probably
shouldn't tell this story
Dirty Laundry everywhere let's go I'm
trying to remember I think he told her
one of my birthdays he might have even
told it at my wedding
uh yes I was a pretty hardcore Sega
Fanboy and I used to convince myself
that Saturn games looked better than
they did somebody I knew what I knew
somebody yeah yeah shut up
wait it depends on what games you're
talking about
I you know I remember when the Saturn
was announced and it came out you know
my mum got it for me 900 back in like oh
my Lord wow Australia you know I just
thought I was so excited I was like oh
my God I'm gonna get Virtual Fighter I'm
gonna get Daytona USA I'm gonna get all
these okay virtual on uh I was just so
excited at the idea of getting all those
secret rally all of it
and I remember I I went out to
Blockbuster music
because they they've had all the big big
video game selection back then so I made
my way into the city
and went into Blockbuster music and I
got fighting vipers
wow I loved fighting vipers at the time
and I got it home and I popped the disc
in my brother was there with me it
played well it played well it was the
closest it was the closest out of all
the games to the arcade I'm not gonna
lie but it was so far away actually
actually it was last Bronx but fighting
vipers is close
I still got last Bronx as well on my
Saturn and I remember I popped at this
skin I turned it on and I saw what it
looked like
yeah
and my brother keeps telling this story
he's like Nick was crying because he's
trying to hide it but Nick was crying
because of how bad it looked that he
wasn't he was trying not to show it and
I was I was like so upset I'm like oh my
God it looks so good but I'm like
amazing
that's why you had to stick to Capcom 2D
Fighters then you would have been you
would have been fine dude
you know worse than that bad new car so
feel
yo shout out to your brother for not
making you feel bad because I had three
of these two dudes I see I know Adam
would have did it to me too oh yeah
I had these two dudes to shame me if it
didn't go right it went wrong
you probably deserved it though
I was I was there and I popped in
Daytona Daytona was the same it just
didn't
like it inside
all right
is that iconic park because I know I had
the tears just like
when you're going up to Sonic and we all
know the big sonic wall and he's
leisurely laying like this
no nick no nick no when the car is
driving and the numbers is jumping
on this is just the guy
bro I remember when they showed me that
I said Sega and Baba I was like okay
so fast oh this PlayStation know how to
do 3D let me go over here
this made it worse this made it
absolutely worse I had the PlayStation
one there and I was holding I was trying
to hold on the PlayStation one was there
and I had Ridge Racer oh
this that's what I knew somebody messed
up over
there don't worry I was got it cried in
the Bronx just like you cried in
Australia I was right with you so yeah
so I I get it's I get the Dreamcast
though because Dreamcast really was that
realization even like PlayStation
PlayStation was close but it wasn't
exactly the same right
um no but but the when you got Soul
Calibur in the house better than the
arcade oh no they really they really
really did it this time yes the dream
cost was just everything was arcade
perfect and it was so high res and the
vmu was like oh my God this is the
coolest thing ever yeah and you know
like for the first year
multi-platz looked better on the
Dreamcast than they did the PS2 yeah
yeah absolutely because the Dreamcast
was so much easier
the emotion engine yeah yeah
uh Toy Story oh yeah I remember that oh
and we're not gonna sell the PlayStation
2 in Russia because we're scared that
they're gonna
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know people forget like Nintendo is
credited with motion gaming but people
forget that Sega used to have
peripherals out there real like they I
had the somebody Amigos
I've still got I've still got the the
fishing rod the cigarette
that's that's what made us that's when
you know you was a huge fraud when you
thought
Sega bass fishing I was a huge fraud I
went and brought it with the little real
device that came with it the big box got
home acting like I care about fishing I
only got it because it was probably one
of the best looking games and it was
made by am2 am2 I was just like you know
am2 does the best 90 for no reason
shout out to that shout out to the vmu
shout out to a lot of where they had
windows or something in the Box yeah
they pushed online yeah like it was just
yeah yeah the library it's like 18 games
yeah the Dreamcast and to a lesser
extent the Wii U but the Dreamcast is
that perfect example of quality over
quantity they didn't have a lot of games
yeah like we were saying before a launch
lineup that will probably never never
been matched again
absolutely ready to rumble
oh man yep Hydro Thunder Sonic Adventure
and Soul Calibur House of the Dead Two
just oh it was Crazy Taxi Crazy Taxi was
available
but if you open it up to launch window
it's even it's even greater again like
it's uh just I mean if your console is
gonna go out right if if if if it's
going to be the last iteration of your
console you want it to be a Dreamcast
shout out to the Chef movie the joints
in there people putting sharing moves
guys of Arcadia I thought yeah Dreamcast
was was something special I do have to
move forward
yes absolute Lord Nick tremendous you
know we can do another podcast in the
podcast about the game because we got so
much gaming stories in common it's crazy
we do gotta move on a little bit um
solve you want to get the super chats
because and then um or you want to get
into the to the pool yeah
because they're killing me right now oh
last week's Ball results are in and the
people have spoken with all star field
now confirmed to get its own Deep dive
outside of the Xbox developer direct
when do you expect to see this
Standalone showcase the winner at our
four-way poll with 45 percent of the
vote was before March 2023 group okay
coming in in second place with 31
percent of the vote was April between
April and June in third place at 12 of
the vote was the second half of 2023 to
King Chagrin and in last place really
close eleven percent of the vote was I
don't care but God Howard must Rock the
brown leather jacket on stage shout out
to everybody who has this uh opinion
Lord addict your thoughts other people
say they want to see the uh star field
before Marchman
oh yeah
I'm right there with you yeah I'd like
to see you too but you know
I don't know if it's realistic or not
realistic because guess what we're not
getting Starfield in a couple days so it
they they left that up to your
imagination unfortunately so we just
have to wait to see what they say no
doubt so maybe they'll give over a uh
a date for the event Wednesday who knows
so we got a few super sensor though um
yeah not too many nah not too many
okay so we got we got Butterball five
dollar Super Chat thanks for the great
shows no doubt thank you
then we got Christopher Hart ten dollars
we could chat because somebody said I
should have super chatted it yes I
married my beautiful wife on January
20th and thanks for the shout out Lord
I have to Super Chat that but next time
at me so I can tweet it out and let
everybody know how stand-up guy you are
because I had to defend him this week
somebody yeah
they don't come for him maybe his online
Persona sucks but he's a good dude
maybe he needs some PR but you know
congratulations brother absolutely
absolutely no doubt congrats bro we have
the rubber knob remember for two years
five dollar Super Chat Australia's awake
morning Lords I would like to announce
the arrival of mini knob born healthy
congrats sir
oh that's what's up then we got a flame
member for two years remember 27 months
actually Lord bronze long that's fine
good afternoon IOP attic was being super
secretive about this guest but it's just
Nick anyway anyone anyone got a shovel
to go out back and bury Halo
you thought about me being secretive and
stuff I did the attic show I was like
you know what I was like because people
was asking I was like I'm not I I I
can't say that like because I even said
I was like I don't think will get too
upset I was like but that that's
marketing Saturday like look for the
Saturday tweets
the
okay you finished at it okay yeah hold
on a second hold on a sec
maybe flame is random disguise yeah
shout out the rain saying such kind
words about me yeah yeah
always lovely always lovely that we have
the rubber knob again remember for two
years five dollars yep time zones are
killer I run my own busy business as
well no time to keep up with the chat
yeah I understand this is true it's
Bonkers to me that it's like 8 A.M over
there it's not as good
then we have Mr Irishman member for 18
months Lord silver shout out to Nick for
saving us gears fans from starvation
now I need to manifest a collection to
come out this year we shall see could be
could be then we have clutch mad five
dollar Super Chat
if you want SOB to read more
questionable super chats tweet this out
more eyes more viewers more Super chats
you're welcome uh
[Music]
let's see what else we got we got
um
ping is overrated look at the icon the
Super Chat chill should it covers about
this first time watching iron Lords I'm
loving the content and dynamic guys you
guys being added to the podcast rotation
thank you sir keep up the good work guys
but I don't know about the name but okay
wait hold on he explained himself
because somebody said yo that's wild
disrespectful son you know come here
like that but he's like no I've had this
name for a long time before I heard of
Lord King it's a play on my name it's on
my name so he can correct it so he's
like this is not to be disrespected I
didn't even take it offensive sir so
question King overrated where did you
come across us if this is your first
time seeing us yeah good question that
is a good question so I saw the Tweet
with Todd Howard
I wanted to find out the truth you know
I didn't get to see that video that
quoted you king oh I was wondering I got
it I know he got it
some this person named King no I got it
I gotta play it I got to play it
gonna play I gotta play because it was
dope um and uh hold on here here we go
shout out to my man Jay Fonzarelli oh
for finding this oh he said he heard
about you from defining Duke oh I
finally got to get to watch somebody
like oh shalu salute all right so y'all
want to hear it here we go let's go
oh mine was muted sorry king of David
who announcer aren't even more proof to
the plow YouTuber King David
personally I've never heard of but I
know people do apparently know him
according to my Discord or deleted a
picture of himself and Todd Harvard with
the quote when Starfield is shipping on
time you just know
[Applause]
it looks like he's hinting now he
probably asked Todd Howard hey is
Starfield still coming out in the first
half of this year I'm told Howard
probably reconfirmed it once again
that you definitely didn't know nothing
about me but everybody that you don't
know me
it was the all-natural situation
we was old Maddie in it
magic magic Gene and um I said yo watch
what I do
yeah you broke the internet you know
what you was doing you didn't just do it
salute the kick you know what I'm saying
yes sir we're caught up all right let's
get to the main event addict this is
your topic
I don't know if you want to set it up I
don't know well look it's been an
eventful week let's just say we're in
terms of of layoffs in 343 and then
obviously the timeline we know big Tech
first started to talk about the layoffs
so Microsoft Amazon Google got a lot of
big Tech um was laid off and then in
terms of Microsoft specifically we did
here and a shout out to gotta got us
like salute the home team first you know
what I'm saying to Lord's gaming.net
we've been kind of one of the first to
report the layoffs the massive layoffs
at 343 and uh shout out to Jason Josh
Joshua running who's able to put that
out and we did hear about you know a lot
of over 60 uh people at least 60 people
three four three and that a layoffs
affected the company as well as people
that were working on the single player
side of the studio so as that news broke
you know shout out to um Jay Schreiber
you know how she paid on the show before
in the realm you know he talked about
specifically the game divisions also
affected it outside of 343 a little bit
of on Coalition a little bit of Bethesda
on the hollow lands team you know um we
hear about them also shout out to our
good friend just going with Windows
Central to also did some follow-up
reporting on that and yeah the news the
news broke you know so
as a result this this went pretty viral
and um then we talked about all Phil's
comment you know in reference to say the
layoffs were painful um but necessary
this is a challenging moment in our
business in these weeks this week's
actions were painful choices the gaming
leadership team had to make decisions
that we felt set us up for the long-term
success of our products and business but
the individual results of those
decisions are real I know that hurts
thank you for supporting our colleagues
as they process these changes over the
coming weeks we'll have many
opportunities to connect and answer your
questions including the monthly gaming
update next week for teams who attend
that meeting I'm in close contact with
the teams at xenomax to provide support
the GLT and I are committed to being as
transparent as we can moving forward
with ambiguity is challenging but I'm
confident that together we will get
through this difficult moment in time
and then the latest in the timeline
um after that was actually we had we saw
about a few uh x 3.3 employees these
voice their displeasure about how things
were handled about leadership
um some you know inciniary comments and
then the most recent state which was I
believe yesterday was
um actually three four three and Halo
themselves actually putting out a
statement and their statement pretty
much read this was uh yesterday 5 p.m
Eastern 343 Industries Halo and master
chief are here to stay because there was
speculation I forgot before that that
they may no longer be the stewards of
the franchise that you know maybe
someone else there were a couple of
reports that went out there maybe
someone else would control Halo so uh
yeah 343 will continue to develop Halo
now and in the future including epic
stories multiplayer and more of what
makes Halo great Pierre Heights Studio
head so this is where we are attic this
is your topic where you want to attack
it bro
um you know I I really just want to talk
about you know your raw perspective on
you know what's going on with Joseph
leaving I also want to go over you know
I do understand they said that they're
gonna retain doing stuff when it comes
to the Halo brand
um I'm skeptical about that because the
way they worded it because if you notice
that it's a single player they said
we're going to continue to do epic
stories and I feel like that's
it's weird word it feels like that's a
little that that that's that's some
puzzle wording where they mean one thing
but you know they say one thing but mean
the other shirt could be I could be
overthinking that aspect but you know
let's say that they don't maintain the
single player anymore and they pass it
on to a studio what studio do you guys
think would be best for a Halo you know
type of Style game uh we'll start with
salt
[Music]
so this is I mean this took me back man
I
with everything that's been happening
with Halo I I was still confident that
you know the idea that you know Bonnie
stepped down and there was just this
seemed like a willingness to take a
Fresh Approach to step back from what
they have try to make that as try to
make that product as as a good a product
as it possibly can be and maybe move
forward kind of a clean slate something
that 343 really hasn't had like 343 even
ever since they took over Halo they're
still sort of in the shadow of Bungie
right and you know whether it's them
taking the single player in a different
direction people not being necessarily
overly happy with that them kind of
being hit or miss with multiplayer like
one game has great multiplayer one game
has a well-regarded single player and
vice versa they will never ever really
able to put it together I think infinite
was the first time that considering the
product that we got overall people would
happen with both aspects of that and my
my big issue if you guys remember from
the beginning
was
hey I think this is the right way to
make Halo relevant again in this
landscape now where we have all these
you know for you know free to play games
and stuff like that that are that are
huge how do we bring Halo back in that
way I think they're free to play
multiplayer stuff was the right move I
think making the single player of this
sort of uh this sort of thing where you
have uh you continue to add seasons of
single player content worked uh what's
going to work anyway
um and but my worry was hey they're
turning it into something else they're
turning it into a service based game do
they know what that entails and are they
ready to put the the time and the
resources and to to maintain that and
the answer the answer unfortunately is
no it just it just for whatever reason
it wasn't happening so it's just sad to
see
um obviously the layoffs I think to me
in a lot of ways I think the industry
sort of looks at you know other aspects
of the industry and say okay this is if
we're going to do this a obviously the
fiscal year is ending in in you know in
March starting in a new one starting in
April so certain things you just if
you're gonna get things off the books
you're going to get them off the books
now
um that's one two just the messaging the
messaging seems a lot you it's it's a
lot harder to get focused on when
everybody's kind of going through the
same thing you see Google you see other
aspects of the industry you see it on
the um editorial side and the and
everything's happening kind of all at
once and it this kind of there's there's
safety in numbers in that regard so I
obviously you look at that you're like
okay nobody can focus on us as we're the
Bad Guys solely because it's happening
across the board so uh to see that
at 343 and they would specifically talk
about the idea that underperforming
teams like underperforming individuals
and teams and stuff like that and when
when you look at stuff like this it's
very hard for me to think that people
operating at this level of expertise
that it they're underperforming it's
it's a team thing where the numbers
aren't there as opposed to individuals
that aren't doing what they're supposed
to be doing right
um so I I don't like things worded that
way because to me I think it's just a
team thing and a money thing and okay
what teams are not bringing the money we
expected them to bring right and then
you put that under the umbrella of
they're underperforming they're not
doing their job quote unquote but
um so you know
obviously 343 has had a hard time
getting Halo you know infinite running
and and kind of to the Cadence where
people expected it to be and that was
always going to probably hurt them in
the long run so to see these people
losing their jobs and to see what
aspects of the game these people worked
on it's you know you look at the future
of Halo and you're like what what the
heck's going on here what's gonna happen
and for me
I'm of the mind that after seeing all
this play out
I'm fine with Halo not being the number
one thing I'm fine with Halo not having
to follow the trend of what's the
biggest thing in game because you got to
remember Halo wanted for halo first came
out it essentially initiated that trend
of big console first person shooters
that were considered to be of the same
quality or nearing the quality of what
the PC was receiving right it was
transformative it was transformative for
the console space where now they're
trying to come back into a space where
there's so many other games doing that
if you think about other genres right
where people have been able to where
Nintendo's been able to take Mario and
bring him from generation to generation
we're placed in this PlayStation has
been able to successfully take you know
their their sort of mascots and icons
from earlier generations and bring them
forward in ways that make sense none of
them none of them have had the overall
breakout sort of appeal that first
person shooters multiplayer shooters
have hats or Halo has coming back and
trying to dominate and be in that space
again is a much more difficult task
because the comparisons right are much
different you have higher quality games
games that are essentially kind of in
terms of bringing in the money these are
the games the biggest games in the
industry so for me
the idea to bring it back the way they
did was solid they just couldn't execute
on it so now what do you do to me that's
the question to me I am happy with Halo
going back to a prestige
release that comes out every five or six
years with a great campaign on
multiplayer Suite that they support for
another year or two so no open world it
doesn't no why because it's too much to
it right there's too much to it and
we've seen that unless they Shake
everything up and they really build
themselves up again in a way that's to
be able to support that it's it's going
to be very difficult for them to do so
go back to making it a fantastic single
player 10 15 hour campaign
a great multiplayer Suite where you able
to expand upon the previous multiplayer
Suite supported with additional map
packs and stuff like that maybe some
single player DLC or or or something in
along the lines of an ODST Edition right
and then five years later you give me
the next Halo game and I think to me
that allows Halo to remain a Prestige uh
uh sort of uh franchise without having
to sort of be this top of the line I'm
number one now right you have hopefully
other games that can kind of take up
that mantle you have a star field that
you hope is able to hit those highs and
you have other things coming down the
pipeline that could maybe be that and to
me if they do that with Halo
it gives you the opportunity to maybe
capture that again because you're not
trying for it you're just trying to be
the best you can be and not necessarily
we have to be this thing up here to me
give it that give Halo that love and
attention and it's still going to be a
great quality product I just I just feel
that for whatever reason they weren't
able to deal with the stress out of of
it having to be the biggest thing on
Xbox
okay so that's just the way I feel
posting this right I was I was all in on
on it being a service based game the uh
the free to play aspect of the
multiplayer to me I still think it is
great right and probably the way to go
if you want more people to be playing
that game
or leaving it as a separate thing and
continuing to make in in the way to Call
of Duty kind of is doing it
um but to me like I just I want Halo to
live and I want Halo to be great and and
to do that
maybe just don't put the pressure on it
to be the biggest thing yeah
bro nah you're looking at it from uh
you're looking at it from the point of
an Xbox fan look at that look at it no
look at it industry-wide industry wide
we're talking it up right the people who
have been with it from the beginning are
talking it up so so my question is
doesn't need to be that end it doesn't
necessarily need to be that to be great
right yeah I just want to push back a
little bit um because I just want
Clarity not the pushback what
clarification I should say so your point
is that because of the expectation maybe
the expectations were too high they were
too ambitious I want to be clear what
you say like because Halo is an iconic
franchise you know for Xbox and you're
saying like maybe because Xbox fans look
at it that way the reality is not that
way and that the scope should be less
I'm just curious well think about it
think about what the school think of the
scope that they that think of the scope
that we as Gamers know this game needed
to have in order to support the game
that they made and look at the the
amount of content that we got there's a
disconnect somewhere there right right
so the disconnect you think it is
expectation as opposed to as opposed to
reality the reality of the failure of
execution and the reality of what it
takes to maintain that right you put
that game out into the into the world
knowing that epic has how many people
working on fortnite every single day to
change and evolve that game daily
it it was always going to be an uphill
battle so if you weren't ready for that
battle
it was going to be super tough right and
then not to mention epic feels like
they're always on the same page they got
they have a machine running over there
whereas whatever internally was
happening at 343 in terms of management
and in terms of different thoughts of
schools of thought on where the the
series should go obviously affected that
as well right engine issues whatever the
case may be
the best case scenario real quick in the
best case scenario
you would need this to oh behind the
scenes to run as fluidly as possible for
them to have a chance to be that right
so for me it was just a number of
different things so when you look at it
and it's like okay how do we get hey if
we if every single time a Halo game is
going to come out it has to be the
biggest thing ever
we're never going to be satisfied we're
never going to be happy and I don't
think the game is ever going to have the
opportunity to breathe anymore and just
be be Halo and when anytime you try to
be you strive to be something I've
always talked about this with with
Esports right a game that comes out with
the intention of being an Esports
phenomenon nine times or ten is going to
fail because it has to be the community
the people that turn it into that okay
okay let Halo be what Halos has always
been be great at what you've always done
and let the community build you up and
make you into something more special
just gotta support to do that
but I feel you I feel like I know I feel
you but again
you want this 900 pound gorilla to act
like a sheep it's not it's no see that
that's a halo fan talking no
friends
here's the thing and then you it seems
like to me the you want Microsoft to act
like Halo is a new IP again and
redefined it like you can't erase Halo's
history No One's Gonna Be able to like
realistically do that why do you want to
keep holding on to it it's the thing
like and my thing is if it's not bungee
anymore right if it's not bungee anymore
right and we that's the thing we failed
to we failed to sort of accept when 343
came on it's like it's not bungee
anymore and we criticized three four
three for not being Bungie more than
accepting them for who they were right
and I get it but the pressure that it
hasn't been set I mean that I get it I
get it but the thing is okay yeah I'm
sorry I can't move forward while holding
on to I can't do it you cannot do it
you're sitting here trying to defend
something that happened 20 years ago
the reason people are criticizing them
is it because they're not like Halo it's
because they're not doing it well we
don't criticize Coalition for the most
part for picking up the Reigns and and
taking the gears franchise from the old
to the new we don't criticize Saint
Monica but but to the new let's keep it
real coalition's been safe it's been
safe apart from the the decision you
make at the end of the last one okay the
games have been gears games they haven't
really deviated that's not true at that
really you want to tell me that opening
feisty today
go ahead go ahead you're saying they
were playing at say safe of a Gears of
War game being a gears game is that what
you just I'm just saying they went and
they took a formula right from another
Studio they took it right and a lot of
the people were the same people as I say
that we weren't and they continued that
they didn't say okay how do we how do we
do that you're not gonna tell me that
gears four was in a safe gears
I see where you're going it was fierce
right here's five it's still gears right
I would admit this is
a transition from five to in Hilo five
to infinite is more substantial than the
transmission I feel like one of the
biggest issues they have is they keep
trying new like crazy things so from
Halo three to four they evolved the
story they brought in new weapons they
evolved the multiplayers people said
it's too much like car then they went
back from that okay we'll try to Reign
it back a little bit we'll make it to
where if you run you don't gather
Shields we'll make it to where you get
shot you get shot of your ads people
said this place too much like Halo like
I I'm sorry I personally feel like
there's no winning in this scenario
there's nothing they can do to truly
make everyone happy okay so what's
what's the what's the answer then why
like yeah let's get let's get there keep
in patient yeah
at least this is what I think has been
Halo's problem for a while I think the
reason people will never be happy
with Halo is because I I don't think
three four three has ever made it
the best version of what it can be
all these little quibbles about abs and
Bloom remember blue
for three years how dare you do you
remember how much crap uh Bungie got for
the bloom stuff in reach an armor lock
yes it's not just three it's not a three
four three thing bungee copped it for
all the changes they kept making to Halo
as well
yeah I just think it was a case of
because you're never going to please
the hardcore fans of a an important
franchise yeah it's just
it's not just the Halo thing it happens
in other big franchises as well
but three four three
their issue was they always seem to get
something wrong
um they never put it all together
yes and then when they did because I
think Halo infinite is only a couple of
couple of things away from being truly
great like I I quite enjoyed the
campaign of infinite I thought it was
great I 100 of it all the Collectibles
I I actually thought it was legitimately
good at the same time I completely
understand the issues people had like
had Halo infinite been stronger visually
yes
they had a bit stronger visually
and had it had its world had a little
more variety different biomes nothing
you would have seen far less complaints
about Halos I agree campaign I agree
with far less complaints I didn't really
see a lot of complaints about the
campaign though I think most people
liked it these are Knicks he that's
right
no pun intended
no but he's making a good point right
especially was right like a lot of
people liked the campaign you know what
I'm saying I like the campaign but if
you wanted to be like critical and say
okay what could have done better not
that it was a bad game because it was a
good campaign but they would say that
like you know biome diversity you know
what I mean yeah it felt like it was a
campaign that was part of a free-to-play
product right yeah and to his point
that's what got them in trouble at the
first reveal right because people was
like okay we want to see the power of
the series X right and see what it could
do with your exclusive title and a lot
of people didn't feel that that showing
was representative that it looked decent
but it looked like more of the same it
didn't look like that graphic we were
just talking about how like the old
generation when you come to the new
generation you expect to see that
graphical Bliss go oh okay this is the
jump and a lot of people didn't see that
but continue Nick I think I think I know
you were going with that and that's
that's what it was it's not that it was
a bad campaign per se but people were
expecting like I said at the time after
that 2020 showing I said back then like
I think Craig could end up being the
best thing that happens to Halo Infinity
because
you know if it wasn't for Craig I don't
know if they would have delayed it
that's a good point damn because
when Satan came in right around Craig
because you've got to remember that demo
you cannot tell me that demo didn't get
seen by Bonnie you can't tell me that
demo didn't get seen
probably by Phil lie down
a lot of higher ups would have seen that
demo and said yep ship it
all good
so they all thought
I assume that it looked pretty good
that's what happens when you're dancing
in the mirror by yourself yeah you think
you got the dance moves everything is
insular you don't you're not getting an
outside opinion and yeah go ahead so yes
Craig turned Halo into a little bit of a
joke but I also think it
I say nothing that's not the right it's
not the right word because in the end
look where it is right did it get safe
I'll handle that part the product that
we could we could we could say that the
product that eventually got released
from opposed to what was going to be
released at that time
I would love to see I I wish you know I
wish I had if I was an Avenger if I wish
I had a power to go to timestones
alternate realities and yes
I want to see what Halo infinite would
have been released in 2020 in November
2020 what was the Halo infinite that
released no man I think uh
I think the biggest issues that I had
with Halo infinite like I enjoyed its
single player for what it offered me but
I do feel like the world felt dead at a
lot of times and yeah uh you know they
would have capitalized on that a little
bit I think what it comes down to it's
like look
regardless if 343 was was starting to
get the hands on things they had a
couple games and you know in this kind
of day and age
you know if they if thank God they had
someone like Microsoft backing them up
because there's not a lot of studios and
Publishers that would have let it
continue as long as it did you know as
far as what's going on now you know we
saw Joseph statenly well you know it
seems like there's a big giant shift
going on at 343 it does look like the
base 343 is going to focus on
multiplayer uh you know from the outside
looking in obviously we don't know 100
of what's going on
um but you know I I do want to go back
it's like if they do
Outsource the single player to another
Studio because there's a lot of people
reporting
they're not they literally the state
because they literally implying that
they are not doing that that they are
the stewards they are literally jumping
in the front yeah I said that it feels
like a conversation happened after that
game spot article and they were like we
have to make a public statement because
people think that this franchise is
going to win it says we will continue to
develop Halo now I mean it may have been
the case and they sat and fought that
like I it may have been the case and
they were like no we can't let this
happen it was weird because out on a
Saturday that's right that's a big I've
never seen
all hands on deck yeah it was like
people think this is going somewhere I
we need to address it okay even if they
continue the single player do you think
that's best for the Halo brand at this
point like they they've already uh laid
off a lot of people in the single player
Department from there to focus
um I don't know like part of me is like
I want to you know stand behind three
four three it's like you you guys got
this but the other part of me is like
at what time
do we need to start looking at in the
mirror issues
it's just like I personally feel like
maybe three four three
they need to just focus on one aspect of
Halo not two okay I think maybe if they
directed The Studio they can get because
I feel like they are very good at that
multiplayer aspect they it feels right I
think it's piss-pull and Part of Me Part
of me feels like let someone else do the
single player
that can make Master Chief in a very
single narrative Focus type of story uh
for instance like I If if what I would
like done and I know it probably isn't
gonna go this way and if it was true
that they might have outsourced it but
now they're going back on it and they
like okay let's let's go ahead and
continue to to try to fix this out I
would prefer them to hand it off to like
machine games or someone someone that
has has proven that they can make very
set piece driven narrative focused
single player first person action
adventure type of games and I would
focus on on a narrative Focus set pieces
put Master Chief in Epic situations epic
moments epic gameplay and then I would
have three four three focus on the arena
and I would have three four three focus
on free uh focus on whatever that Battle
Royale that's going on right now uh you
know really make sure that that comes
out as best as it can and obviously
they're going to keep battle passes and
stuff like that and I would rotate the
the multiplayer function by an arena and
Battle Royale because I do think there
is a point where
I don't think the name of Halo's
downgrading I think the competition is
upgrading you didn't have fortnite's
rolling wild back then you didn't have
Apex Legends run wild back then like
and I think that you can't compete with
that without a free to play Battle
Royale game you just can't look at look
how long fortnite has thought or still
stood around and they don't seem to be
slowing down Apex Legend has been doing
good War Zone's been doing good like
this formula works you just gotta make
it fit Halo no but you gotta you also
have to give it to you next and then
Kings be patient you also got to have
the infrastructure to support it and we
could say oh this is great but if the
thing that used to get Destiny in
trouble back in the day was that that we
used to like yo what's the live team
doing right because you had to tease us
making the expansions the DLCs and all
that right but then there's the people
who deal with the day-to-day
monetization model the infrastructure
what's coming the smaller drops and it's
clear that as much as we like this game
and it's a solid game that they didn't
have any legs to support it for the
duration it was like everything was just
to get it across the Finish Line it was
such a struggle to get it and then when
it finally got there it's like okay we
did the we did the math we had it was
fantastic it was fun we did the maps I
mean we did the regular content but
after the maps kind of got repetitive
and we're like getting a new maps and
then we start to see what the actual
they were they went to the point where
some of the monetization tracks on the
battle pass was like left shoulder pad
right you know a little flamey thing and
it was very messy was trash got to be
honest with that it's the live service
aspect that I'm with King that it it
show it exposed that they didn't have
enough in place to continue what I I
don't even think I don't think it's they
didn't have enough people in place I
think it's just they had random people
doing this random people doing that
situation they they uh obviously that
that's a whole can of warrants by itself
we won't get into that too much but it's
just like you have to go into this
knowing that Destiny didn't show up the
way it is but you should easily be to
use Destinies faults to teach yourself a
better model in the future right and to
me outside looking in it honestly felt
like they didn't really think too much
about the aspect of what happens
post-launch what are we gonna do Post
launch like and then it looked like they
didn't really look too much into
Cosmetics either because when you look
through something like like fortnite you
look through something like Apex Legends
yeah you look through some even
something like Fall Guys when you're
getting that season pass that battle
pass you're upgrading from level to
level to level you're getting drastic
cosmetic changes that makes you validate
okay I bought this 10 bucks it's fine
you get stuff like like Deku from my
hero that that will want you to pay 20
bucks for that skin you get stuff like
Apex legends that has some crazy looking
Cosmetics I just feel like they didn't
really capitalize in the Cosmetic stuff
so what did that result in lack of
funding because they're not making money
off the game does that result in giant
layoffs of people that ain't gonna do
this stuff anymore okay can I say one
more thing if we got to get Nick and we
got to get yes real quick so I agree
with that like I said those are all the
reasons why that stuff didn't succeed
they didn't have the pipeline for that
now there's another argument that I
heard a lot of also was just the fact
that Halo is a different type of shooter
than what people are used to being the
top of the line Shooters today or the
the arena based shooter the weight of
Halo is different and it doesn't appeal
over the long term to as many you know
modern Gamers now as it did to us and
still does to us and the fact that that
if that never changes
Halo won't reach those highs again
regardless the only pushback solve is we
have to be honest
when even though when they get to my
turn I'm going to talk about launch
dates but
when it launched
it blew the internet away
it did let's keep it a book like they
were leading Steve it was a Resurgence
like I've never seen it was almost the
multiplayer Team literally saved the
game
right then because when we remember the
morale was so low coming in
the year before we then we knew about
the delay Satan comes on I remember us
doing the iron Lord stream
at the uh back and forth Bethesda
showcase and they showed multiplayer for
the first time
and people were like hey yo that looks
fun hey yo this looks great the
repulsive flying back and then when it
did the stealth drop right they did
because it had like a snow drop
multiplayers available whatever whatever
it was a Resurgence I never seen I was
shocked that it was that received so the
only pushback I say is that if it was
done right with everything else and they
had this the legs to sustain it they had
a wave they I remember that people would
say yo the king is back remember people
remember
yeah
I think what it is is
shipping the game at that point when it
comes to games as a service
in in a weird way is the easy part the
hard part is entertaining the people
weekly daily and keeping them coming
back weekly and daily and that is the
most important thing in the games as a
service and I feel like that is what
they felt the most and what eventually
led to the downfall of Halo incident
because it wasn't long before steam
started dropping numbers and then I
would say well we we had to look one
week we had to look in and Halo wasn't
in like the top 50 bro most play games
on Xbox hey thanks to more than 20
million players Halo infinite had the
most successful launch in franchise
history especially since Hill infinite
multiplayer went free on a multiple
multiple platforms and not to mention
that on the Xbox game pass they were
popping off they were like but we've
said that the the actual
the the gameplay of the game is it is
addicting and as good as it is
eventually we have trained a lot of
people growing up in this era that if
you don't reward me for what I'm doing I
don't care if the game plays good and I
think that's what happened people didn't
feel rewarded enough playing it and they
eventually went to other games of course
yeah that's 100 True January Halo
infinite continues its top selling
success on Steam they were ahead of of
all these other on Steam Five Nights at
Freddy's or whatever it was but yeah to
take a 800 900 pound gorilla and turn it
into a sheep not gonna happen no no it's
good I just want to just kidding but
they did it to themselves they just they
did it of course of course
but I wanted you to finish your thought
before I go with the kid
has a bit of a point which leads me to I
think a lot of that excitement that
carried Halo at the start was purely its
gameplay yes like people were
discovering how good halo felt again
because it does infinite feels and that
could only take amazing
but then what happens is once that
excitement wears off and this is I'm
speaking from my experience now and
others I've spoken to once that excites
I'm playing multiplayer and I'm loving
it oh my God how good does this feel and
it feels great but then all of a sudden
you start noticing the desync yeah and
just like yeah you start getting real
peed off about it
and then all of a sudden you're like oh
God I'm playing on this map again
[Music]
this is like the 57th time I've played
on this map and you start to notice that
there's not that many maps all of a
sudden that's a good point and then look
and once the the the shine of how good
the game plays starts to wear off all
those mistakes and all those poor
decisions they've made
started to come to the fall absolutely
and then all of a sudden the battle pass
sucked yes and then all of a sudden why
who made the decision to have cores that
had specific pieces of armor that could
attach to them why would you just let me
do it like every other game does it
where I could just stick anything to
anything like this you know I said it
back then I'm like so many games had
already given you the blueprint their
own games obviously had to go why did
you go and do
your own random thing that like
look that especially that core thing
like I wanted to buy the cat ears I saw
the cat ears everyone else I bought the
cat ears but then I couldn't put them or
the suit that you wanted on the helmet
that I wanted and I'm like
don't make anymore this was a great idea
343 had that idea and all the others
were like that's brilliant
let's let's restrict everyone's choices
with their armor cause and then let's
let people spend 20 on ears but they can
only put them on the helmet
good point though you're right stuff
like that that's what I think has hurt
the game more than just this little
little bit decisions and you just that
that's why I I think the biggest problem
with three four three was probably the
leadership as most devil
continue
can't blame the foot soldiers that are
just the names that are doing whatever
they're told to do like there's a lot of
good in Halo infinite that shows there's
obviously good people at three four
three but we all saw the stories how
many times did we seek this director
left this director left that director
left this director left Halo infinite
had so many directors I I had lost count
like
it was yeah I don't know what was going
on at the top of three four three but it
seems fairly clear that there was issues
there and
like I understand Eric's point about I
don't think it would be a bad thing to
have three four three be stewards
of Halo so you know I I think it'd be a
cool idea to let three four three a
smaller three four three team of project
managers take pictures from other
Studios what do you think a Halo should
be what do you think Ayla should be
one bad mother was in the chat earlier
that's kind of how Nintendo does it
people don't realize Nintendo don't make
a lot of their own games it would
surprise a lot of people to discover
that it's not actually Nintendo making
Smash Brothers it's not actually an
interview
that Smash Brothers was um
Nintendo making Kirby it's hell that's a
good point Nintendo don't own
um Nintendo overseas they supervise they
make sure that the standard it's
following the rules it's doing all the
things
I I don't think it would be bad for
three four three to do that but to me
I'd prefer before they go that route
just try getting the leadership right
first
and I had hope when Staton stepped in
but I wonder now why he left
um
when he went back to Global yeah he was
there before he went back so yeah like
I I just wonder why he didn't want to
stay on or actually was it him not
wanting to was it Microsoft saying right
right forget Halo we're pulling the plug
go back to publishing like I'd love to
know why
Staton is not there any more questions
because we all thought we all thought oh
well stayton's there now give it some
time and they'll fix it they'll sort it
out I didn't think that but
no we must have stayed in there look no
okay kick with patient I gotta get that
idea I didn't think that at all let's go
okay let's go well I'm just curious I'm
curious as to why okay because I love
Bonnie yeah ah so okay
for you guys and I remember you guys
jumping off the roof with your elbows
out y'all was Macho Man Randy Savage
it's like yeah Bonnie's gone
hello
it's like yo we got her out she was the
one that was
[Laughter]
what are you replied I'm just I'm just
letting it soak in I'm just letting it
wash over me okay okay because when when
the first signs of trouble Stayton said
I'm out of here well we don't know what
I mean I need I need well we need
clarification right yeah
look
and when I when I say
I didn't really have a problem with 343
games uh you know Halo games throughout
that whole period of time you know they
hit a Miss on certain aspects on little
things it was like man you right there
man you write it that's what I always
felt like it felt like you you about you
about to you know touch the finger God
you're about to you about to do the
bungee connect you you almost there like
he was just right there so we thought
Halo infinite was gonna be that thing
Craig face popped up where he's like oh
buddy yo and they pushed it back and you
right Nick I really honestly believe
that them pushing it back saved you know
uh the franchise to be a big block by
Chicago's right when it did hit when it
did drop bro when it did land it it had
an impact crater you know when people
was like oh my God the king is bad I
remember that I remember that
who's there for that she was um okay so
attic is right for them to go up against
the juggernauts in this street like
fortnite the way epic moves behind
fortnite the whole the whole company is
behind this machine right the way that
they're able to switch it on the Fly
they can drop the game down they can do
a down time for an hour and do an update
that yeah that's what I'm saying they
cannot do that single player and compete
with these companies right they can
right because even even fortnite dropped
fortnite save to save the world right
push that thing to the side because they
they focus on the multiplayer it's so
it's either or
Halo isn't relevant
I know that sucks it isn't relevant to
our children today
right and the reason why I'm saying that
is and this is where I was going to give
you flowers it solved
oh no I'm just I I don't I don't like
being right about this this is true this
is true to the fact that any kid that I
know from eight to let's say 15 to 16
Nick's kids they run straight to
Roblox Minecraft fortnite then the
little older ones from there Call of
Duty
uh uh Apex Legends
gation impact
ain't nobody say no Halo all right and
they did it to themselves I I had
first-hand experience playing the
multiplayer it was good playing it was
fun and then it got to a point of
redundancy where the season pass became
non-essential yeah it was really and
then the goals for what you had to do
was idiotic
like I had to wait for a certain map to
do a certain thing
horrible it was just it was just wasn't
thought out properly and like Nick said
you had people come before you step on
those rakes ahead of time you didn't
have to come behind them and make new
rakes and step on the same old rigs
right you did this to yourself
all you guys was calling for three four
three to be closed now here comes the
fake outrage oh they're laying on people
at three four three you'll get it
you went to Twitter and said oh man they
not doing it right
but King they're not doing it right
listen
you can't have it both ways it's either
it's dysfunction and mismanagement
and they have to reevaluate and fix
or it's leave them let them continue
what they're doing so now that we notice
we recognize the problem
we're fixing the problem don't cry about
the outcome hashtag 5343 that's what you
reply no I'm not saying five three four
no I'm talking about that's what that
what in your defense yeah but I told you
before let it burn I told you before let
it burn
now
see people don't know how these big
companies work they have ai algorithms
that go around and assess your work
because a lot of these dudes are still
doing remote work from home
all right so they're knowing how how
long you're actually working on said
project they understand you come in with
a number you have a number this ain't
like how Google did it Google you walked
up to the building your car didn't work
you just was fired
I'm pretty sure that they said listen
the valuation time is just just that in
the third Performance Based stuff
probably redundancy is there probably
1099 workers you have no idea but this
is fake outcry from fake people that
really don't understand what's going on
into the situation
we don't know you you just don't tell me
that they had a top developer top
developer a got fired highly don't think
so
I do not think so what you mean all
right so again
layoffs happen we understand that there
was a huge bubble attack bubble uh
during this time of the pandemic a lot
of this money was given out for free to
these tech companies a lot of this money
is uh was you know you didn't have to
even have to pay it back the PPP loans
for big companies
there was a lot of overhead money they
made a lot of hires during this period
of time they had to build a lot of
infrastructure now that you're seeing
that everybody's going back to work the
world is starting to go back to normal
yeah not everybody's staying at home and
they lost outside
some of this is definitely normalization
right it's it's it's coming down to its
normal Peak that's across the board I'm
not trivializing the the the
4.5 percent of uh loss that was lost
but in this industry
if you look across the boards towards
everyone there's going to be layoffs and
turnover right hopefully that everybody
is get you know has a uh gets a little
parachute and it's around tax time so
they can actually get to the tax part of
the season have some money and then you
know look for another job and hopefully
those credentials roll over into the
next job and I want to I don't want to
get into the whole business aspect of it
343 itself was in crisis we can all
agree on that we don't think that they
were managed properly we can all agree
on that yes and we thought that uh Joe
Staton would uh write the ship I didn't
I thought that he was brought in there
to get that multiplayer Tip-Top shape
and I believe yeah he got that stuff
done
gone right back to where he was going I
did that part now it's up to them to
ship that Battle Royale thing to see
what they're gonna do get away from the
slip space engine get to the Unreal
Engine 5 engine uh from the stuff that
we've been hearing in the background
Stark to control it solve is right that
Halo doesn't need it I I say it's a
little bit longer I say eight years I
say every eight years you get a good
idea wow but the reason why is they have
enough Studios now that you don't have
to put a priority in a mandate see you
in five years it doesn't have to be the
number one right but it it can't be
anymore
I don't believe it's relevant you have
to build it uh attic put out a tweet
that said the brand is suffering
you have to build the brand and build
back trust into this product faction
yeah this is where the problem is we
don't have trust in the product it's not
saying it's not a 800 pound gorilla it's
still a 800 pound gorilla but is he as
ferocious as he once been right he's an
800 pound gorilla that's exhausted from
always being in the news
it's gonna it's
I'm happy
that the shake-ups happen Okay but I
don't like the fake outcries of people
being terminated and stuff being moved
around and Halo might not have the these
people are leading it for it they came
out they told you they're leading it for
it this is going to happen it's just
they turned it into a fanboy War I mean
that's what I didn't like about it I
mean this is
Halo though yeah this is the best and In
fairness if I gotta play Devil's
Advocate In fairness this is the same
company that has an intent to acquire
Activision Blizzard kick so the talk is
if they can't manage their own Flagship
title how can they hope to manage all
these other Studios they look to acquire
that I don't feel is fake outrage I
filled out this is a valid question that
people can present and say you got to
get your own house in order before you
think about doing other things okay we
all know and I've always said it was
only one Studio that was putting in the
bad reports I agree right but it is the
studio with the flagship title that
literally got you into gaming are they
cleaning it up now right I mean we gotta
see right we gotta see I mean I'll jump
in look I know where you're going I know
where you go oh look let's start with
the human element first you know the
layoffs hit home for me personally
because one I think
I was just surviving the wave so to
speak in my own sector you know it's
terrible you you I have tremendous
empathy for that because you don't know
where your future is going to stand and
it's scary you know what I'm saying like
we really don't know so salute to
everyone you know who who definitely is
trying to figure things out I want to be
empathetic to that second can your right
as far as across the board big Tech is
getting hit across the board let's just
be clear Amazon meta Google Salesforce
everyone like pretty much record name
this is everybody I do agree with the
fact that not that there was an over
confidence in a pandemic climate but the
remember during the pandemic it was
record numbers crazy engagement now that
the world has kind of normalized you've
seen the change now and now there's
course correction however I will say to
me the surprise that I was when I saw
when it when it came to Microsoft
I mean I wasn't too surprised no
disrespect with the hollow LED stuff we
didn't see any Community you know
commitment there and they've been kind
of clear that they're moving away from
that but I was surprised the Xbox game
studios the gaming division hit right
now to me we got to be honest the
comparison of layoffs for everyone else
compared to how much 343 got was a big
disparity right and then we saw you know
they saw reporting lordsgiving.net that
we saw that it was a lot of the
narrative team right to me this is where
I'm back with you King is that what this
indicates to me we got to talk corporate
now right when you look at your company
as a whole
you look at what's underperforming in
terms of investment right we can all say
rather how we feel about Halo infinite I
feel it's a great game I actually do
feel it's a great game on its core level
I think it's a great game but we have to
admit it must be internalized as a sales
failure because this is an indictment
you don't go attack this team
specifically unless you feel you didn't
just again you did you didn't feel you
got the return of investment based on
what you put in so that's what it is you
know I want to be clear though again if
I do it I kind of we don't agree with
Kingdom I like this website but the um
the thing I do agree with him again is
that again when people come up to me and
they say [__] Xbox game studios right I
have to look at it objectively I'm not
take my Fanboy out of it
you look at the whole Coalition
delivering on time the Guinness
franchise for my understanding still
okay you know what I'm saying you know
obsidian since they've been in
everything damn near they put out have
been on time it's been fine playground
greens before the Horizon we got to
speak about it we know what the track
record is turn 10 with the forza Main
Line we know what the track rate is I
know people don't care about Minecraft
but guess what Mo Yang we know what the
profits is you know what I'm saying it
is insane for them and the list goes on
as far even I'm not even the world's
Edge Age of Empires is huge you know
what I'm saying what you call it um
what's the other one from um we got the
Minecraft we got even though rare I'm
not a sea of these guys
it's huge I got I have to the only
people you can say is you look at the
new guys right and you can say where
they at I personally can't judge it's
like you own a new record label I got to
see you put out your first album before
I can say you you you're a failure right
so until I see Ninja theories thing
we'll see what Bethesda does with
Starfield field then I could make a
judgment and say okay but if I look at
it as a whole
the rest of them are okay but like King
said we look at one and if someone comes
to me and says yo Xbox game studios is
mismanaged look at what they did to 343
I can't fight you I can't argue with you
I it literally has to be mismanagement
you can't say it's not you know I'm
saying if you look at it it's
objectively but mismanagement at what
level I'm gonna break it down here's my
thing okay
the way I feel
you know they went through a series of
of changes right and the reason why it's
an indictment on mismanagement in my
opinion is because this studio
in a sense operates in a silo and that
their whole soul existence is to be the
steward of Halo that is their whole
thing is to handle everything Halo
related so when it comes to they have
their own publishing they have their own
consumer products they have their own
media inside of Microsoft this is a
special like team it's like a special
forces in a way right just your sole
purpose is Halo right so if I look at
that and I hate to do it but we gotta we
gotta pull out the resumes since you've
been since they've been in existence and
I've said this a little bit before and
fast I don't care what nobody say Master
Chief Collection is literally unplayable
and a disaster of a launch I remember I
wanted to get people to to get the Xbox
One people were like yo I'm interested
I'll wait for that I love those Halo
games they remastered the old ones
remember they did the the presentation
the here's before here's the new it
looked beautiful it was literally
unplayable I've never seen that on a
major launch with a with a franchise
that's supposed to be the steward right
so we gotta wake off yes brother
off-road we got to keep it we got to
keep it a buck on that right then Halo 4
graphically outstanding three four stop
they think stunning okay I Gotta Give it
up but we know about the multiplayer not
well received right then we get the Halo
5. we already know about this story I'm
gonna say the multiplayer was fantastic
I loved it everybody loved it but the
story The dysfunction the way it was
handled with the lock situation it was
just not good it was not received by the
masses it's good and then we get the
infinite which we've already said core
gameplay great you know what I'm saying
get caught campaign for the most part
silent some little nitpicks but overall
package it seemed like they did it we
like oh they got the multi player they
got The Campaign and now you have no
support and now you have no legs on a
model and it's just like you just prove
that you can't sustain the 10-year plan
that you yourself said was going to be
the the you know the thing and then
let's be real you know to addicts point
we see online these scathing indictments
from x343 developers scathing
mismanagement incompetence
um then we see State and leave where a
lot of people feel like yo that's the
Savior though he's on he got it across
the Finish Line to kick you know what I
mean now he's gone so the the morale and
the confidence is Shadow and to me I'm
very upset because
how does this happen to Halo we don't
talk about what is going to be the
future of Mario
we don't go to Nintendo yo what's going
to happen with Mario y'all we don't know
is they gonna still make Mario games
like this I'm sorry I'm gonna be
emotional this joint is so important to
me because soft King y'all know
November 15th this game was born
November 15th Xbox was born November
15th is my birthday you know what I'm
saying like literally I'm synonymous
with this this thing launched in my city
The Rock was there Bill Gates was there
everybody coming in here saying yo Halo
Halo this is the thing I'm like why why
everybody rapping about hell remember
the reviews
this Halo game you got to play this Halo
game I'm like let's see man
system link you'll say blood coach Hang
Em High pistol bro it was it was bored
it was like yo this is great console
game shout out to Golden down we respect
you but console first person got no dick
I know golden Niger baby I love you but
she ain't Halo
bro top five bro you know it we brought
four physical TVs
we learned how to beef makeshift Network
Engineers because the Bolton player was
so good I drew it with a Lexus router
ether that Cat5 cable was because of
Halo we had dudes in the projects put
TVs outside the project playing Halo
King come on like Halo means everything
how does this happen to Halo that's what
hurts so it's just like here's the thing
and I'll bring bring it back because I'm
getting emotion look
selfishly
I would have loved the 10-year plan to
work because that means Halo Infinity
still exists we would get expansions we
would get me what is it Halo endless
whatever the rumors were you know a
Battle Royal and then I was hoping that
that Cadence will continue not saying
that it's not going to happen but now
everything is is in flux you know what
I'm saying we don't know what's going to
happen here's my last thing that I wrap
up for me this is what needs to happen
again I'm just outside looking in I'm
not a Dev I'm just saying outside
looking at you know this is a stain we
just can't ignore this is a stainless
the black eye it's really bad I love
that they put the statement out what I
would like to do shout out to Pierre
hence I'm trying to have hope because he
was one of the people
who was put inside when Master Chief
Collection was Master Chief collection
and now turn Master Chief Collection
around to actually collection is
actually popping and probably more
numbers than incidents right it's
unbelievable now what it is right
absolutely absolutely so you got that so
I'm hoping for that now the thing though
for me and we got to talk about they
talk about it briefly
they're the I don't know if they're the
only Xbox One Xbox game studios that has
this problem but it seems like they have
way too many contractors
and if you're looking at Synergy and
building a team either a convert those
contractors into full-time employees or
B phase out the contractors and have it
where there's that sentence you can't
have a great team in my opinion where
people are flowing in and out 1099
workers yeah you can't have the floor
especially on a custom engine thank you
not good like 100 like you got to have
that Synergy that consistency and look I
gotta say look Phil you're not like Matt
booty I know I love you but I gotta pull
an at it it's showing me your build time
with 343
it's it's it's this is what I mean by
that is I love the hands-off approach
when it comes to acquiring new Studios
right because that's what got them in
but let's be honest the resume has shown
with this particular studio and the
importance of this franchise right I
would love a little extra checking of
the homework so to speak a little bit of
maybe some random check-ins like it
something has to change on the process
because the only thing I can believe and
I'm just gonna be honest
is that
I can't I can't see a situation where
they didn't check it
me personally it's just Cox talking I
can't see a situation where they didn't
go in so to me there's a disconnect from
the developers that are saying that they
put in the hard work to do what they
were doing and they were getting stymied
or whatever they were saying
to the mid management who's supposed to
now tell Phil and Matt booty what's
going on right there has to be a
disconnect
you see what I'm saying some the message
is not getting to the top somehow I'm
not putting a blame on that specific
person but clearly you can't tell me
that Matt booty and Phil Spencer never
stop by right so then what happened
where it wasn't a guided situation like
like you know I like when the boss come
through if you ain't do your homework
and then you try to show there's one
chapter that you did like what happened
it got it got to be show me your bill
bro like almost something has to change
I don't think you're gonna have a
problem going forward that and that's
what I'm hoping for the good thing about
public embarrassment and the good thing
about this is everybody watching you now
everybody watching everybody watching
you down so one would hope you know what
I'm saying that because of this
there's some random spot checks Villages
popped through bad booty just pops
through you know what I'm saying maybe
there's some a different change in the
processes as far as deliverables and
things of that something has to change
because I in my opinion I have no
evidence I think they have to dig that
engine I think whatever it is this is
probably the biggest problem because
even if if they go and they stay with
1099 workers or whatever yeah you have
to get them up to speed on that engine
that's proprietary engine that you've
made that's probably not even there
anymore either make that you know I
agree either make that real engine five
well you're gonna switch it I mean or
make that call where you give the
resources needed and the time needed to
think and the last thing and I still
don't got Ray tracing yeah I'm about to
get to it
completely forgot bro that was the thing
you're gonna get to it because the same
thing like and I hate it I do this to
y'all but it's like look
use this place and I know I'm gonna get
a lot of flack for this kid gonna hate
me for this please use this as an
example in a warning sign for Starfield
well
please use this all these dudes on my
timeline Cog Halo infinite gotta drop
with it gotta drop hey so what it don't
have for your launch so what it doesn't
have campaign
it don't got Ray tracing it the game
must drop [__] it must don't be selfish
and hold up to get are you happy now
with the state of the game your Flagship
hobby you happy
listen you because yes because Starfield
is just as important the success of
Starfield is better than some eagle and
some make it come out because Gamers
feel it should come out
this is
real talk Sunday we doing real talk
Sunday don't listen again because these
same dudes who was yelling talk about
hate needed to come out look at it now I
don't want that for starfish
take your time because they forget they
forget I was on them bro could you
imagine 2022 with the baron 2022. I'm
finished I'm gonna let you get your boss
2022 could you imagine if Forza Horizon
was popular in the end of 2021 let's be
clear Forza Horizon 5 had the city on
luck
you could have easily pushed it into the
2020 to win and guess what had co-op on
launch had Forge ready to have the
content just given to you consistently
by your own community and had a game a
live service game rocking and rolling
fully featured for 2022 when you were
Barren with no star field and no red
fall you can't tell me that wouldn't
have made a difference having a full
package of a game that's all I'm saying
is no need for the Russian question over
here with this other guy no need
direction no
Kool-Aid over here uh no soft talk
Sundays and uh yeah Todd don't listen
let's keep going yeah see Todd ruin the
game Bring It Out Half Baked and then we
worry about the Studio's future you
heard it here
get gangster list Sunday we kicked David
cause he would have a list to talk to
y'all about so no I don't care about the
list just make sure you make it on time
all right that's it I'm done this is
funny but let's I'm sorry I've been
talking long time anyway I just want to
say one last thing
and for me it's like all the things you
said technically about the process and
what has to happen within the studio for
things to be successful is 100 true but
I think a lot of what a lot of why there
was stagnation besides the the what you
would call it the uh the engine and
stuff like that and contractors come in
now is it felt like there was always
there was always sort of toxic energy at
the top when it came to being on the
same page as to where Halo has to go
if you don't get that right and you
don't have management at the top that
they can agree to disagree and they
could go back and forth and together
make a product that they both think is
superior most a single player realm and
the multiplayer realm if you have
management
battling each other toxically at the top
for for competing ideas as opposed to
pulling them together it's gonna
continue so again like like you guys
said
more than anything fix that fix the
culture around Halo it's the culture
around Halo everything else will fall
into place because you'll all be on the
same page and that's what I hope man at
the end of the day like I don't want any
of this to be true I just want Halo to
be great whatever form it takes I don't
really care Halo I just want it to be
great and it doesn't have to be the
biggest thing on Xbox anymore I just
wanted to breathe and be fantastic yeah
I think we beat that to death oh
super Chancellor yeah we had a couple we
got a couple
more
we got a few
okay okay when I was talking initially
there might have been a few that passed
me I don't know I didn't get who this
one is from it says for me the only way
to bring Halo back is to kill Halo
infinite there is nothing but negativity
attached to that title now need to break
that ball and need to break that ball
and chain I didn't get the amount of the
Super Chat no other person this was from
so I tried to scroll back and I was not
able to so attic if you could look at
that and see if I missed anything and
then the last one I read before that was
the clutch man one about me reading's
questionable super chats so anything
between that that's when I was talking
and I missed those
um and we got Hot Grits nine ten five
dollar Super Chat to be real Microsoft
having these issues because of
transparency so only a Nintendo don't
let their fans know anything until it's
near ready yeah that's true yeah we
talked about that last week too like
maybe just wait two three months before
you
don't give us anything to talk about
that's it just speculate
hi casares 15 Super Chat Halo needs more
employees to make different types of
games in the universe not less it's just
ridiculous that we don't have a horror
game or an Arbiter solo game yet great
show Lords and yeah so you could
definitely make a flood horrible yeah I
agree
but we have Mr two opinionated two
dollars per chat a lot of people say
Halo and gears are past their Prime
okay it's not true I just think they're
not relevant yeah and we have Tai
casares fifteen dollars per chat people
also expecting Halo to be the top dog
again when there is more variety in
games nowadays that's the the playing
field is a lot different than it was
Mr Irishman member for one year 10 pound
Super Chat three four three should treat
Halo how lucasfilm treats Star Wars
games and licensed Halo out to other
depths to make single player spin-offs
like ODST while they focus on Mainline
games with the chief okay
then we got JD gamer remember for two
years fifty dollar Super Chat thank you
for that
until and unless Microsoft is willing to
and execute execute setting up a Dev
pipeline similar to Epic and UB which
are designed for open World Service
based games backed by an aggressive
marketing campaign like Halo 3 was when
they can't and won't reach hold on won't
reach that next level and that is true
that's what we talked about it's like
they turned it into a service based game
they didn't have the pipeline to take
care of that
so Mr the two opinionated two laws of
attack Act is on point that's all he had
to say yeah yeah yeah I'm starting to
think Mr too opinionated his attic
then we got gigs both on ten dollar
Super Chat of all the news this week
Halo is the talking point it
crystallizes industry biases fans want
Halo to be God of War and Destiny no
game is that also divided on what game
should be equals impossible IP to manage
we talked about that they got to be on
the same page they got to be on the same
page
I don't got JD gamer once again remember
for two years ten dollar Super Chat Halo
infinite needs a relaunch whenever the
next major content update takes place
and then aggressive marketing campaign
behind it we're talking Super Bowl NBA
finals week 16 and big movie teasers and
ads
I I think that may be wishful thinking
but people don't use terrestrial
television anymore
the way they used to yeah Instagram
greetings launched the wording of 343i
leaks and Angel statements make me
believe it's it will still have
spin-offs like Minecraft great show
great guess thank you appreciate that
man brother we have JD gamer once again
two uh member for two years twenty
dollar Super Chat my uh my idea for Halo
produce a 30 minute in-engine story
content and gameplay Loop using all the
tricks of an upgraded slipstream uh
engine using all the power of the Xbox
series Exodus to debut in theaters and
the second season of the TV series
man he's out there with the cross Media
stuff I mean again anyway
it's difficult it's difficult to to to
kind of Market it to everybody and
everyone the Synergy of both teams have
to be it has to be there then we gotta
waiting to us yeah they got to get they
gotta get their house right first flame
too loud Super Chat slay [__] slake
bars stop stop sucking up to the boss
that's right
Halo so don't pay him no money
known Halo hater
oh yeah that's like crazy
there we have Suicide Kings two dollars
Super Chat whatever Cog Works y'all fire
him Microsoft needs God oh my God can I
stay employed though
[Laughter]
exactly the move the move is in place
then we have Persian night ten dollar
super chat 343i needs to recapture the
incredible maps and gameplay Halo 2
multiplayer such an incredible time
absolutely sitting on map sitting on
maps let's move on we got uh especially
next segment and a little bit of uh Lord
saw segment because I know so I'm not
the Avengers thing but I do want to take
advantage of a special Nick dropping
some bars recently but um let's talk
about two things man one you mess with
my heart thick man I hear these these
scale bound talks you know I get
emotional so I need to know about that
the number two uh Xbox era podcast last
night had some interesting images on
their screen about the gears franchise
that got the internet
on fire so I let's start with these two
things first before we get into the
Avengers
yeah which one which where do you want
to go let's let's start with scale
Banner man am I am I getting my hopes up
man with my Platinum
Platinum what's going on if you heard
I like I had so this is interesting I I
had been told that
Platinum was doing stuff
and at first it was just so
team ninja ruined my Rumor Mill
when they did their interview saying
we'd be we'd bring a Ninja Gaiden back
yes I was like literally that weekend I
had a rumor mill lined up which was
Ninja gaiden's coming back and it's
being done by Platinum
now all team ninja said was that they're
bringing Ninja Gaiden back right
so I was like I asked my person I was
like can I just say that platinum's
doing it on Twitter I'm not going to
worry about it on the show they're like
yeah put it out on Twitter so I put it
out on Twitter
at the same time they said
big Platinum might be doing scalabout as
well whoa and I'm like no way I'm like
like everyone else I was like no no
chance
so
I went to
my Microsoft person sources I was like I
was like look
I got told a couple of things about
Platinum
needs your garden
and apparently they might be going for
scale bound as well okay okay I'm like
can you look into this for me because
this scalebound thing no way like surely
they're not going to
they went and looked into it for me
they're like Ninja Gaiden yep
um
I need that I need that in my life I
need to get right I need it
and they're like scalabander heard
nothing I'm like okay so it was probably
okay nothing just yeah all right anyway
about a month later
about about a month later out of nowhere
I see a little notification in my
Discord
[Music]
and it's a skull bound
GIF I'm like
oh no I'm like you have to be joking me
they're like
I think there might be something going
on there
but I had to sit on it for quite a bit
and then I was massaging them because I
said if I I'm not a journalist I'm not
grub I'm not here tomorrow take the
title don't worry about it nothing
they for whatever reason I'm just a
vessel
I am just the messenger I am not
an Insider person I just I know people
who know people yes
you realize that's literally an inside
yeah
so just just to clarify you think Jeff
bro tell it all you think Jeff Grubb is
making these games and then he's leaking
them no he is told by someone else that
he leaks it this is offensive situation
he doesn't want to be considered that
he's the middleman I like that term it's
just the vessels
remember like a lot of this stuff
doesn't come necessarily from people
like that work in the studios or
whatever it is it'll come from
and actual The Insider that knows
someone like I've asked a lot like okay
so the person that sent me the gears
picture yesterday Live on there whoa
spoke to this person I said why don't
you like I ask a lot of these people why
don't you leak stuff why don't you leak
it like why are you giving it to me I'm
no one why why me
they're like
because we don't want to deal with the
crap you're going to deal with
haha
yes yesterday on Twitter for example I
saw a couple of accounts talking about
the image
Sloth sir hey you've been slaughtered
I saw all that on Twitter and like I
looked at a lot of the replies and I'm
just like
oh nikolai's make stuff up
I saw that that's the stuff that the
people that send me stuff don't want to
have to deal with like they don't want
to deal with people going through their
history that I want to deal with people
like I know it's just words and I've
always been one of those people that's
like ah it's just words who cares but
like when it's constant and it's
incessant and especially when I I think
I've been pretty Upfront for the for the
whole journey see what a lot of people
don't realize is that I've actually been
doing this for three years I didn't just
start teasing and leaking stuff six
months ago it's been going on for about
three years
and
what what people don't understand is
like I've been very upfront about all of
it I've told people how I get the info
I've told people where it comes from
I've even publicly shown some of the
redacted DMS if if I saw someone leak
something first I'll say it like you
know a while back we had a rumor mill
about rise too
um
because I had heard rise 2 was coming
hmm
but before I said anything I looked into
it and I found another Twitter account
that had already leaked almost all of
crytek's roadmap
when I had my Rumor Mill I was up front
and I said look I'm not first for this
info there's a Twitter account called at
poke your protos that leaked the
entirety of crytek's thing right I was
completely upfront that I wasn't the
first of this info and I've always been
that way so I always find that online
abuse are weird I don't think I've ever
hid anything I've always been quite
upfront
so
you know with scale bound
I had to sit for a little bit and then
because it came from two sources I was
like so am I okay to go with this
and they're like
okay go for it but make it clear make it
clear that this is probably a long way
away okay like this is this is early
days which is why I said at the time I
don't know if they're gonna restart I
don't know if they're going to pick up
the pieces of what scalbound was in when
did they cancel it was it
2017 2018 something like that was about
right it sounds about right that window
I don't know if they're gonna pick up
the pieces of that I don't know if
they're gonna start again so it's
something that's probably a Fair Way
awake okay okay
um what I mean other people have pointed
it out Platinum themselves publicly said
publicly outside your defense thought
they out here they're asking asking yeah
begging back and
we spoke about it on our show back in
September remember that interview Phil
did and they asked him about scalaban
and he was like no comment I'm like
so we were on our show we were like hold
on why is he saying no comment if they
weren't looking at scale bound why
didn't he just say look didn't work out
projects canceled we appreciate
everything Platinum the the usual
standard it was like no comment
um
hold on a second I got my DMs not too
long after that okay so I'm like
it was all a very weird situation
but I I look I
just based on the things I've been told
I think it's gonna happen all right so
for those of you because I like the look
of scalebound as well
so for those of you sure it does
it played like
[Music]
um
horrible I played the first showing is
good ah no I'm I'm talking about that
vertical slice joint that they put up
there I'm talking about this The Joint
that was on the floor and when they're
not in my head yeah it was like that it
was it should have been on the floor it
was it was I I don't get the infatuation
with this game I don't get the I don't
even like the fact that Microsoft legs
is tied and Shackled to this game and I
wish Sony would have came through and
purchased said game long time ago and
finish the development so you guys can
get exactly what you're looking for
because this is a this is this is the
one I can't wait
that was during the Xbox One this was
pre-corpio days
come on the es red wasn't enough all I
remember that game I remember the
dialogue I remember how it played
that game I look at that game and it has
a whole lot of energy like a game that's
about to release this week that is
getting ripped for all of that corny
energy that it has oh you're trying to
throw for speaking for smoking on it bro
I'm looking for spoken and it evokes it
evokes scale bound to me and
let's cover your cook man let him
cooking if it is a brand new thing that
has nothing to do with that
Vision New Vision New Vision just one
energy something more something more
grounded and maybe more serious than Oh
serious
but again just the name alone could be
an albatross on the around the necklace
oh so you can't be names I mean though
like I said I've always said you're
gonna bring my scale mouth you make it a
panther Dragoon game
you work with Sega but I just to me my
my worry I will say this quickly my
worry with this cool if they kind of
come back whatever gears I you know
gears is coming you know gears is good
for the fact that it that stuff leaked
it's coming maybe we hear something
about it I know they were working on
something else other than gears because
they wanted to take their time with
unreal fives so that's great
uh for me my warrior with Platinum is
what Platinum do we yet
if this is real do we get do we get
Bayonetta
um astral team near automata platinum or
do we get babylon's fall we don't talk
about that you don't talk about that
that's that's
okay
it's a valid it's a valid concern like
let them uh Infamous for taking on too
many projects yes yes so that's that's
my worry they're known for it yeah yeah
no that is my worry and then somehow
they managed to convince Phil to go with
the old idea
the fact that they're working on two
games at once there's a good chance one
of them isn't going to do very well
right
yeah I I hope it's not the case but we
we've seen time and time again when
Platinum Games is working on multiple
games their a team is what makes the
bangers and the rest make what they make
and if you're with IGN Japan presidents
Platinum president
anaba and uh Hideki common were
effectively reflected on scale balance
constellation this isn't just wishful
thinking the pair wants to have serious
talks with Microsoft about revisiting
the project both Kami and I are serious
we really would love to work on
scalebound again I'd like to discuss it
with Microsoft properly I'd like to
appeal to Phil Spencer directly let's do
it Phil he wants to be a couple let's go
what was that
publicly said it publicly this is
February in 2022 top of 2022 baby now I
will say this I will say this I like the
fact that they you know the way that
relationship so that whole situation
made them look super bad and I know I
know everybody at the head of platinum
like really felt that they they stepped
out in front of her like no it was awful
we were working announced the deal for
ABK
January January January right right it's
a year ago a year ago yeah so yeah so
Platinum saw oh snap
yo I really really
because you know um I feel that we had a
we had a good working relationship so
you know
um
man they see money floating in the air
that man well we did have a product and
if you didn't like something we can go
back and fix it
we were working in it and I quote we
were working in an environment we
weren't used to we were developing on
them
we don't want to date you we like it
we know how to build a big colleague
I'm sorry to the players who look
forward to it moreover I'm sorry to back
us off who placed their trust in us as a
business owner and I want to apologize
and friends at Thanksgiving do you mind
if I come over
I personally feel like oh and the reason
my camera's out I don't know why but my
camera keeps overheating
um I think it might be that cord okay
the cord that plugs into my PC I don't
know we'll figure it out with no hot
chords uh but yeah I personally feel
like
the scale bound thing the only way I can
realistically see that happening in the
end is if there's like an agreement that
they buy Platinum yeah I just I like
this I just I find it hard to imagine
Microsoft nothing this managed
I definitely don't
need those guys those guys is a
lukewarmada
part of me feels like if they
if they didn't have to to juggle so many
projects we would see a different
Platinum I'm not a big Platinum fan but
I do think that if there was a
conversation where Microsoft talked
about buying Platinum Games and one of
the conditions was from Platinum is we
really want to finish scalebound and
Microsoft agree to that I do think you
would see probably one of Xbox's best
Studios
they don't have to make 10 15 games
anymore they can make one or two what
Focus the majority of their Studio on
one or two and you'll get the near
automatos all uh the uh the chain one
that came out on the switch
it out
I'm talking about quality like you're
for the most part I do think that you
know even though I don't like playing
games if they were put under a platform
holder and got the proper budget you
would only see that type of product from
there that's for you guys it's like
dating Chris John Rock
look at me how pretty she is when she
got her tooth in her head as soon as she
take her too fast you get crazy off that
honey yo we don't want that
[__]
now not at all please we don't seen
enough red flags from these times
let them be who they are if any time and
I'm glad Phil didn't answer him I'm glad
that happened all the way back then the
deal is done no it's not
think about it you're telling the deal
is dirt did not come out of e3 with
these dudes on stage because this is
when y'all gonna start to see the
beginning of the end
I I don't know but pardon me like as
much as I'm not the biggest fan of them
I do think their type of games is
something Microsoft is lacking third
person yeah yeah in that game pass
me and you don't like these type of
games but we can't act like when they
hit they hit hard and when they don't
hit they hit harder
[Laughter]
I don't know why they ain't hit hard
like that and it's there is excuse
it's because they they have to it's like
what obsidian and Ninja Theory said when
you when you were an independent studio
and you have to rely on solely yourself
you end up making games for people that
you wouldn't normally make just to keep
the lights on you don't feel that let me
see what happens but I appreciate you
dick or that and then again just to
clarify you know we saw the image so so
here's something whether it's collection
markets that'll be good oh no the gears
the gears story I've been like clear
about I I screwed up with the gears
collection with my source okay that's
the one time I've ever got in trouble in
three years that's the one time I've
ever gone in trouble I
I leaked it too early no just way too
early and I got in trouble for doing
that okay his collection's happening oh
and I know there are still people that
like Jess and Rand have openly been yeah
get his collection's happening now that
image is a different ballgame that image
I again I was very upfront on the show I
said it was all happening in real time I
was getting these DMS on Twitter and
this image just popped up now it's ran
yeah again I saw I saw the horrible I
saw horrible comments on Twitter oh look
what he's doing for clout now it's like
guys I wish like you saw me distracted
on the show I was getting the messages
but what people didn't see was the
entire image I was asked to crop that
image
very important stuff so the the image I
posted in isolation and I said to
everyone up front it's one of those
off-screen images yeah you do we've seen
a hundred million times over the years
those off-screen at an angle made to
look as real as possible all that sort
of stuff so when you see that image it
just looks like the other million
off-screen images we've all seen over
the years
what makes me believe in its legitimacy
is what you didn't see in that image the
path that I was asked to crop out
um that is the part that makes me think
it's real as in the image again these
collections happening so that that part
don't worry about 10 toes down on it
okay I'm now strictly talking about the
image I was gotcha okay okay what makes
me think that image is real is what you
all did didn't see and say my person
that sent it to me because even the
person that sent it to me they're like
oh I got this a while back but
I 100 how agilities I feel you on that
Nick but as like the person on Twitter
looking on Twitter and when you say a
statement like that I'm sure the first
thing that comes to their thought is how
convenient that the thing that would
make you see real you had to crop out
no because
um
a lot of stuff that you get in your DMs
sometimes they tell me you know you
can't say nothing about it assistant why
are you why you send it to me that
that's my thing like I don't care to
know a lot of stuff so if you got stuff
don't send it to me because I'm not your
hard drive and I'm gonna let it out
you know so um don't do that but I
understand what he's saying where
the part that will make it believable
he can't show
because he was asked not to show that
part yeah and you can show this part and
I know somebody's gonna say oh it's
convenient either you believe it or you
don't yeah you know so if it comes out
that it never comes out it's never right
then you can go on to it and say oh Nick
was wrong and if it was right he trust
me I'm telling you Nick ain't gonna run
you down and say see I told you so cause
he don't care he was just giving stuff
and he was taking that he was taking
that smoking then come out he's right
Rand and Jay's are going to get the
others
in good defense I've seen Jazz kind of
Teeter now I'm like oh he's Nails yeah
he's like I might have to stick the
special Nick is right I'm saying
something there may be some Credence to
this there might not be a lot of stuff
that I get down the Grapevine that jazz
gets doesn't know and you could tell how
he tweets on Twitter uh but what I will
say when it comes to that is it is nice
when you see Jazz like straight up deny
a rumor and he was like oh your people
ain't heard about that like he's
ridiculous no but Nick
I believe you and thanks I really no
Nick I really believe you
um
[Music]
real quick after you finish it because I
do want to get this Avengers thing in
yeah yeah no I just yeah the the gears
collection like I said that one I'm not
backing down I continue to not back down
and I've had like you know again jazz
jazz is one of those video game
journalists that
like waits for Fairly yeah Rock Solid
proof yeah absolutely um
so you know when he was that first being
like yeah his collection's not a thing
and you know look I kept getting people
doubting me like I like again behind the
scenes not just publicly behind the
scenes I was getting
I'm not I don't want to name them
because they might not want me to but I
had other people saying to me in DMS
going dude
I don't think his collection is real
it's not real and I'm like
the doubt kept said again and I kept
going back I'm like oh this guy's saying
it's not real this guy's saying it's not
real this guy's saying it's not real and
they're like it's real like it's real
they're like stick to your guns it's
real so I'm like okay I'm gonna stick to
my guns here and your defense jazz is
slightly turned around on this one and
now Jazzy's just like oh hold on there
may be but the reason is again like I
said I got in trouble I leaked it way
too early gotcha not many people knew
which is why I think I was getting so
much of this isn't real this isn't real
um
a lot unfortunately for me a lot of my
stuff is early I mean look at Persona I
was getting so much crap for Persona or
you said persona was coming to Xbox and
blah blah blah blah
but again when I mentioned Persona like
the deal had just been signed as a
persona Atlas aren't known for
developing games quick
so it took like over a year like a year
and a half for Persona to finally come
to Xbox like
that's the issue now whether whether
people want to think a year is too long
or
like I don't know who judges what the
timelines
I mean it just it is what it is like I
know I get you at that point I totally
get you on that point and then it's
basically you got to kind of get the
smoke up front and then you got to sit
on this book for a while but then when
it does come to fruition you get to you
know you get to say I told you so you
know in there yeah it's just I don't
know I find people like to pick and
choose what they remember what they
listen to what they don't like
it's just uh actually you know what no I
won't tell that story I'll tell that
story
because there's there's a relationship
there yes I'll talk about it off here
we won't stitch on that yeah it's just
it's one of those things where I just I
don't know like King was alluding to
earlier
it doesn't cost you any money to not be
a jerk yes it's free it's completely
free to not be a jerk like absolutely
when I've seen people on Twitter who act
like they have leaked something or
whatever my gut instinct isn't to abuse
them if what they're leaking or talking
about is something I'm interested in my
first thought is I hope they're right
that's that's my first thought like when
I saw the rumors of a clanoa remaster I
was like yeah please let that be real oh
my God please sick
ler Noah was amazing oh yeah oh yeah
absolutely you fit
if that doesn't come true whatever that
person is leaking okay I My Life Will Go
On at the end of the world it's not like
I don't know I just I find the people
that get irrationally
angry and abusive about that kind of
stuff I find it odd yeah no like the
king said I mean just choose not to
believe believe what you want to believe
or not and I said there's no need to be
aggressive disrespectful or whatever I
do want to get solved real quick with
the um Avengers thing because I know we
can get um what happened man it's over
it's wrapped yeah it's over
they finally they gave us a date when
they're gonna take Old Yeller out back
and shoot him in the head oh yeah about
two years after its initial release
Crystal Dynamics has announced that uh
development on Marvel's Avengers will
cease
on the 30th of September at which point
uh the game will no longer be available
digitally
um although single player content and
the actual multiplayer will remain
intact at least for the foreseeable
future
um you know
what else is there to say is that they
this is this is the warning shot this is
the one that everybody should look at
when you're trying to make a service
based game and
taking a property and a license that
nobody wanted to be this type of game
and then turning around doing it
incorrectly
and this is what you get ultimately at
the end of the day I think there were
people a lot of people that played this
game that you know kind of religiously
stayed on top of it shout out to Greg
Miller who I know who religiously plays
this game I know people are playing um
and for me it was you know I think from
the very beginning the talk around it
was disappointing because the service
based stuff is not what they wanted from
a full-on Avengers game especially from
Crystal Dynamics a team that is not
known for making this type of game they
people are used to seeing Tomb Raider
and you know third person action
adventure games from them which is what
was the expectation was here and a lot
of people felt like the single player
stuff was good at least story wise
um it just never hit that it could never
ever separate itself also from the
multiplayer aspect of it which many
people just felt was completely
undercooked didn't utilize the the
property well in terms of I don't know
if this is still true but I remember
when I played it like you got you got um
you were able to get like uh like
different suits and stuff like that but
suits weren't visible in the game the
suits had attributes that they acted
almost like armor underneath just so you
would your attributes would improve but
you you wouldn't get the look of the
suit in the game like it was a license
thing so the Cosmetic stuff was never
really a thing which is in a game like
this is what you would expect it to be
in terms of what you're purchasing and
stuff like that so it just it just felt
like it just it started off on a bad
foot and never really gained its foot
again they finally decided to shut it
down so I don't I don't think anybody
any one of us really really played it
all that much but I may be wrong I'm
gonna play a little bit I'll jump in
yeah I mean you know they're not
surprising but um you know look it's a
beautiful game I always tell people
Crystal Dynamics made a beautiful game I
mean from from out of all the games that
came out I felt like it was a next-gen
looking game somewhat when I when you
played it on the big boy systems you
know I think it was cross-platform but
it did look good
um yeah like you said live service just
felt tacked on when I was really done
with it when I was just like okay how do
I play co-op with a friend and I
literally had to play like a bunch of
missions to unlock a co-op section Hub
or and I was like this is too convoluted
so to me it wasn't really made with that
and the surprise boy the single player
stuff and the story was actually good
actually a decent story being told I
think I picked up the um also the Black
Panther
um expansion or whatever you know what I
was I thought it was good but it just
wasn't equipped for the live service
model and again like you said to me
cautionary Tale you know if you're going
to do that model you have to really
fully commit to it they didn't seem
equipped to do it and here we are I mean
shout out to them at least they got to
give all the marketplace and cosmetic
stuff for free after a certain uh again
after their part they're getting
everything and there's not going to be
any low future content though after that
now in Petty news and Petty news
Spider-Man is still going to be
PlayStation
[Laughter]
the funny thing is just like it just
shows like people love to to clown on
Destiny and you know I don't play it as
much as I used to people love the cloud
on Destiny Warframe
but these games have pulled a formula
that these other million billion dollar
companies are desperately trying to get
and they can't find the forms the facts
big big facts we got Anthem Marvel
Avengers division
the division is Halo infinite like
people try so hard to get that formula
and it's not easy games is a service
it's probably one of the hardest things
you will realistically develop for yeah
absolutely that's a hard it's a hard bag
that's pretty much all I got on it
unless anybody got else anything yeah
I'm done
I'm struggling I I'm not I'm not gonna
call me on anything you've mentioned
Spiderman because we were talking on our
show about Avengers as well yeah he I
heard what you said this is going to be
interesting
it was one of those things like I said I
don't share everything I get oh there's
some stuff I listen to it and I'm like
oh I think I'm gonna stay away from that
like I'm learning the filter stuff and I
remember a long long time ago I actually
found the DM because I couldn't find it
in my one note and I found the DM
I found the DM in my OneNote yesterday
it was back in 2020
this was I've been sitting on it for
nearly three years
because at the time Avengers was just
about to come out or I just when did
Avengers come out when did it come out
it actually launched around launch I
felt like it was one of them close to
launchers because it was still uh uh
last generation current generation game
the sad part about that game too and I'm
sure all of you they had probably one of
the biggest IPS at that time that they
could have ever have done so imagine if
they instead of trying to turn that into
games as a service they had like a
cohesive story that went through
a Galaxy
a set of villains that and you just keep
rotating between these characters during
the story so what was this yeah it would
have been great what was his name real
quick before you know but yeah at the
time and I I said nothing at the time
but now the game's been canceled it's
been long enough I could probably show
anyway here was uh sorry August 14th
2020. yeah
August 14 2020. oh wow so this DM was
like okay
um
this guy at the time had reached out to
me and said that there may be a loophole
to get
Spider-Man in the Xbox version not
straight away but later down the track
and I was just like are you for real
like there's no way known Sony has not
put a million and one right
Claus is in that contract to make sure
that never happens and this person's
like oh there may be a loophole in there
that where Spider-Man could make his way
to the Xbox version I'm gonna be real if
you know the way I saw that I just want
to say the way I saw that man swinging
they can keep that
that even The Swinging the shooting the
shooting
let me finish
the trollage would be crazy yes yes over
here that's that's all I was saying
though he was just telling me at the
time now now back then I asked him as I
do to everyone that sends me stuff I say
hey is that something I can leak is that
something I'm allowed to put on Twitter
or am I allowed to mention it on the
show and they were like yeah yeah you
can but make sure you say ABC now I Then
followed up and said look how far away
do you think this is right
and they're like uh it's probably he
mentioned it was sometime well into the
future because as we know Sony's
contracts are very easy long term so I
was like you know what dude
I'll leave it if we hear more later down
the track and it's more definite then
we'll go with it and I never said a word
what what you heard on our show and what
you're hearing now is the first I've
ever mentioned but it's just another
example of I don't like
if I was some kind of guy who just makes
stuff up for attention you don't think
mentioning Spider-Man on Xbox would get
that attention oh for sure oh for sure
for sure no that's like it's it was it
was a funny day it's very very casual
but without this one this is one of the
rare ones where they might keep that's
what I mean because it wasn't that
exactly like anything that I'm used to
and there's Zumba Zumba Spider-Man
wasn't any good oh bro you old you
didn't see I didn't play it did you look
at it did you look oh boy oh boy
Spider-Man
um for Marvel Avengers gameplay footage
oh boy yeah we was like don't ever let
them do Spiderman if inseminine
Insomniac is not directly involved we
don't want to see he was able to see he
passed Spider-Man's uh you know flaws
with that Spider-Man Insomniac is just
such Gods when it came good
I mean I brought the game when it first
came out I was all enthusiastic after I
saw what they did to the Hulk from the
rip y'all can take this game and Chuck
it into the ocean
um story was fantastic oh
yeah what's he doing yeah that's what
he's doing oh yeah
what's his whip shooting that's exactly
what he's doing
electric company Spider-Man yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know what's crazy that's
one of the like
that's horrible it's such a bad look on
Sony like having so much pool on
Spider-Man and Sony looked at there like
yeah that's it ship it
to them they wanted it and they got it
this is like scale bound oh man
he said that DLC looked like your dad
dressing up for Spider-Man during
Halloween
I told you guys when uh Whatchamacallit
um embrace the group got them and it was
like yeah now embrace the group It's
Gonna Let You some flourishing they say
yeah we're going to support all the way
through all that sounds nice until you
see how much the electric bill was over
[Laughter]
here what they paying what for let's cut
that game off it's not bringing in the
numbers he said what about Zumba
Spider-Man it ain't working
with Spiderman listen get rid of it I
thought the story yes or the single
player was grounded I thought the story
was great I thought they got the script
and I felt the same way when I played
Guardians of the Galaxy I said wow they
really nailed it on this thank God it
wasn't a huge success with how messed up
it was just really messed up like when
you go into the Hub world and you had to
find your mission and then your friends
was linking up with you one person
couldn't be a certain person and the
attributes that you did get was like a
hologram on your arm you couldn't really
see those things uh on on the character
I was cool with it they had a lot of
good ideas they didn't flush them out
before they launched it I think it was
rushed I think the story part of it was
good I think the the games as a service
part needed to bake a little bit more
yeah and they didn't get that
opportunity and it fell flat and they
got blamed for it and it sucks that the
game is um but you know it lives on
right uh we we still have the game we
still have the single player we're going
to get all the extra stuff that is gonna
drop for it and it and it is what it is
but they did tell a good story and if
anybody want to play the single player
it is a good story that way I would not
recommend the games of service uh for
myself shout out to ASAP gamer he out
here snitching the um the Xbox era
situation or last battle Xbox I put that
out but y'all go check out Twitter is a
little interesting right now they're
getting hyped again they love a special
dick situation with the with the league
but look we got to come by because we
going crazy long well you can try man
drop by okay so don't you drop them okay
we're gonna do the thing okay oh yeah I
don't I don't want to touch it because
somebody somebody texts me in the DM
it was like just don't talk about this
one thing that happened oh God we leave
it alone yeah yeah plus we're at time so
I mean we we came out a good we've been
at times we've been that time for a
minute this is probably getting up there
but look let's um while you get the
super chats ready let me get the um pull
and then we give a nice little exit out
but um okay so with the latest layoffs
at 343 in the Studio's most recent
statement on their commitment to Halo
single player and multiplayer what do
you think is the best course of action
for 343 moving forward the choices are a
slowly pull 343 responsibilities away
from Halo to other Xbox game studios B
continue to deliver on the promise of
Halo infinite with continued single
player and multiplayer content drops
C Clean Slate slowly phase out Halo
infinite support start development on
the next Halo game with the Lessons
Learned or deep I don't care I still
want my Spartan lock spit off game those
are the choices please rock the boat
when it goes up on ILP Twitter yes Cog
is trying to kill the stream before the
49ers give you absolutely right I am
guilty the 49ers might play in half hour
you're absolutely right I was looking at
the time no cap oh anyway salute
dispatch so that the crossover finally
happened Rock the entire way from
Australia Down Under the man got up
early in the morning
no doubt where can the five people find
you hey what do you have gold wings car
got to be somewhere in 30 minutes yes
that's what's your history no let's not
do that let's not do that because the
diet is about to play the Cowboys and I
need to see that so Nick telling people
where they could find you what you got
going on Sir uh yeah I'll keep it short
and sweet I just got to xboxair.com
You'll basically find everything there
the forums the reviews podcasts the
whole lot uh I'm at
special underscore Nick on Twitter if
you want to follow me then
hear me talk crap
that's that's about it
thanks again for having me on though
that listen man much love to you the
team professionally done podcasts
professionally run site shout out to
sick I gotta get all sick on love his
energy love the chemistry you guys have
shout out to your writing team great
guys over there one bad mother I believe
you're already a couple I'll always good
camaraderie good energy when I check out
the stuff and um keep it up man y'all
love what you're doing over there always
a fun and I'm glad we got it done Lord
yes addict where can the fine people
find you what you got going on sir you
can find me on Twitter at Lord addict
IOP you can find me on r r with the
Lords this Tuesday with uh me and King
David we'll be talking about the second
episode of The Last of Us there's gonna
be a lot of things yeah I'm gonna enjoy
that yeah I'll be sure not to listen
thanks
a lot of trailers have popped out here
recently too so that's going to be
interesting well I want to thank the um
the chat man you know
that you guys showed up today we had uh
I think almost 850 900 people in here
today you know you guys show up every
week and you know when we go to this
paxy spam we we we really go we
we go every year but we always try to
level up the previous content for in
terms of uh you know quality wise so we
did what we we got to do you know uh we
we cover a lot of stuff when we go to
these events too but I appreciate it for
coming through yeah we'll see you guys
next week and you know like I said man
uh definitely check into me and King
this Tuesday at 5 p.m on uh r r with
Louis you're gonna like this week so I
won't be there yo why am I catching
Strays already
[Laughter]
we will be we will be most likely how
many of the Lords can make it to the
Wednesday thing
you see you see right
hey shout out to Microsoft for putting
it on when I'm actually traveling so I
won't even make a movement to get to see
it right there Mike yo the Lord South
the rebellious Lord where can we find
you
the one who must be borged I'm sorry
yeah forgive me the one lack of r r
presence oh my God I know every time I
was I was there first thing with a 20
Super Chat yes no doubt hold on this is
the truth so
yeah I what I'm gonna be doing I gotta
go to work so that's what I'm doing
right shout out to Nick Nick I have a
confession to make I've been following
you an Xbox era for the longest right
but for whatever reason I never I never
read your name properly right
so I I never saw it as special so I'm
like oh we got we got shipper show up
Nick coming on yeah
that's the Destin legary ones from IGN
he was like shape shelter
[Laughter]
[Music]
first my fellow collector uh much
respect and much respect on uh you
getting up and you know you being here
especially on your month off when you
could be you know energizing and getting
your your batteries back up but you went
back to everybody see you gotta look at
the Integrity of the man went back to
everybody that you told that you
couldn't do certain things and you got
this month off and he was like yo y'all
can get it in now I want to uh you know
get on the shelves and he rocked all the
way out all right so this is his time
for leisure to recharge his batteries
and he is here so I truly respect you
and thanks you have a lot of information
that's in your DMs I know a lot of
people come to people especially if they
have websites and they have shows and
you know they want to find a kinship
with you so I can understand them
sliding you something yo this is what I
heard and this is what I found out but
don't say this right so
or say he's not an Insider he's just a
vessel of of holding these secrets and
he holds a secret for a long time on the
Spider-Man stuff and everything so you
know go easy on them pause uh when he
puts out information and if you don't
want to believe anything that he puts
out then don't in fact you don't got to
slander it a lot of times you could just
shut up and look you know you don't
realize
the thing is you don't need to say
anything because I put out a tweet with
Phil and I I got a bunch of negative
comments this is the first time I had to
block people in Mass wow yeah
I don't care what you think about him it
was an Eclectic environment celebrating
the accomplishments of a man that has
been at one job for 35 years until you
can be someplace for 35 years you
probably ain't even been on this planet
for 35 years
stop coming for him unless he sent for
you so you know Nick is just being
special Nick
and if he has information that he wants
to share he would do so you don't have
to comment under it if you don't believe
it if you don't care about it you can
keep scrolling going someplace else you
don't need to bring the negativity to
somebody that's trying to bring
something positive to you all right
that's all I got to say he's a great guy
thanks rocking out with us and I do love
it and I can't wait to be on your show
yes have fun with you have a good show
yeah yeah like I said Wanda and Dutch
brought me two
um listen tomorrow I'm gonna be on with
Colt uh tomorrow night I'll be on for
for an hour okay for some reason I'm in
high demand this week oh yeah I wonder
what it is
all that all that Insider information
yeah it must have been that uh stuff
that I put out
oh yeah
he loves the NDA people so you fit right
we're gonna have a good time
um or no RNR with the Lord yes sir
all right so tonight I gotta watch at
least uh two or three episodes of uh uh
um Attack on Titan right you gotta do
that then I'm watching this thing called
sick that addict got me watching attic
is sick
um
then I have to watch The Last of Us so
this thing that we've started
has me watching more movies more shows
and doing it with a Discerning Eye like
I have to be focused on every part of it
I have to listen to the music I have to
listen to everything because I want to
give you an accurate description on what
we're watching and and how it makes me
feel with certain things so this it's
been a very fun ride in what we're doing
um I want to thank everybody that
contributed to our road to pack
East 2023 this will be going on all the
way until we leave so um you support
here you support on r r with the Lord
you support on this show this week when
we do it um for the Microsoft show
please support please come out and we
promise that we're going to give you the
best content that we can possibly give
you but thank you for all the support
that you do give and everything is 100
appreciated thank you no doubt much love
you already know stops get these super
chances getting out of here we got
Gordon fiala 20 Super Chat thanks for
caring thank you sir appreciate that no
doubt then we got post up five dollars
in the chat what's good everyone salute
to the panel you guys is looking real
crisp in New York thank you thank you
good to see you brother good that you're
feeling better man we was pulling for
you for sure love that you're doing
better
and we got Mr Irishman remember for one
year two pound Super Chat yeah get scale
bound to make metal gear rising too yeah
okay let's do that oh oh exclusive
exclusive yeah
let's do it now let's give a minute
let's give him the ball give him
something else man come on let's go
let's tell it was actually it was
actually
no I think it was someone on Twitter one
of the actors or something from metal
gears oh yes you said yeah the actor who
plays writing yeah said something
probably something coming soon and then
I went back through our old shows and it
was about we had Charisma Williams who
was from Microsoft at the time and in
that rumor mill for that episode I had
said there was a couple of things I
mentioned I mentioned that Final Fantasy
XV would be announced in 2020
one and that there might be some
PlayStation exclusivity with Final
Fantasy
yeah this is what I mean people forget
the stuff I've leaked in the past but
what I also got told for that episode
and I said at the time I'm like massive
grain of salt on this one
was that we might be seeing Metal Gear
Rising Revengeance too
and that there was a chance it might
even be an XBox exclusive whoa that'd be
crazy now this was like a while back
this is now I said to everyone back then
I'm like this is huge grain of salt on
this second one final fantasy 16 is like
okay
[Laughter]
let me tell you something and this is
full disclosure full full full
disclosure and we were so close to
getting out of here you know no no no no
because you know why people people you
don't know really the backstory because
people got goldfish memories
but listen please do good
cogs and and and loads of gaming.net
damn
first big big interview in person all
right here okay what's Platinum games oh
he's trying to say buyers
they they they they had him he ain't
requested in in uh
hotel room
yes oh yeah
one-on-one my man was dead microphone
set up everything ready to go
I was proud of the interview and that
that interview went up that that the
writers went everything perfect they
gave him a shot yes so listen I'm not
being disrespectful when I said I don't
want Microsoft person everything I'm not
being disrespectful I want ABK to happen
so you can come back and double back
around the block
everybody
is because you gave us a shot
and Cog is a loyal do
he's always going to look for the
positives in you and he's going to
bypass the negatives
I'm gonna point out the negatives first
classes always happens
it's the best two dollars he's ever
spent
[__] my [__] definitely is he he
respects exactly that shot because that
shot meant everything to us yes sir yes
sir fair enough I don't know what you
talking about
I don't know if it was this I don't know
which time uh yeah
I don't know I don't know I know these
guys did a good job I know those guys
didn't shout to the team shout out to
the team so this is if y'all see why Cog
is doing this God bless
I'm just saying I just said the receipts
is always real
[Laughter]
[Music]
Ninja Theory and or Tango Games would be
a great team assist with scale bound
also it should be single player only yes
please
then we have Lawrence Davenport member
for two months five dollars per chat
Platinum can make scale bound and we all
get the Bayonetta games remade for the
Xbox I don't know how that works the
Nintendo published it was not listening
to what you talking about yeah it may
not happening then we got Stitch
[Music]
[Laughter]
remember 30 months actually boy bronze
shout out to the realm the Lords and
Nick thank you sir appreciate it did his
thing
then we have Donald tackle member for
five uh five dollars per chap the only
bad Platinum games are licensed games
with no budget and short Dev time and
one live service game everything else
they put out was a one that's right
she's beautiful but she sleeps a lot
he always crazy
one last shout check out a level one
gaming grow the community great show
guys and Wednesday will be very
informative yes yes and they just
recently had special nickel on himself
go check him exactly he made his run
over there
there we got space channel five five
pound Super Chat peace peace Brother
peace
I think we are good to go yes we made it
everybody enjoy your Sunday again salute
a special Nick so with everybody that
came out with everybody supporting the
goal more fun things planned a lot of
cool things I'm really excited for we
can't talk about it just yet but that's
all we got anybody anybody else before
you know another seven hour podcast
Birds
[Music]
thank you